İyi akşamlar arkadaşlar 23 Eylül 2024 Pazartesi günü 25. ders günümüz saat 19.30 dersimize başlıyoruz kaldığımız yerden devam edeceğiz ses ya da görüntüde problem olursa bildirin lütfen değerli arkadaşlar.
Nerede kaldığımızı şöyle bir hatırlayalım evet en son kaldığımız yer arkadaşlar virtual dispatch mekanizm sanal gönderim mekanizması nasıl implemente ediliyor derleyiciler tarafından.
Şimdi bu soru iki açıdan önemli bir maalesef mülakatlarda sorulan klasik sorulardan biri fakat burada aslında bence önemli olan virtual dispatch mekanizmasının implementasyonunun maliyeti.
Yani içinde bulunduğumuz bir durumda virtual dispatch uygulayalım mı bunun bize getirisi ne olur götürüsü ne olur onu konuşmak onun kararını vermek.
Çünkü iyidir ya da kötüdür diyemeyiz genelleme yapamayız ne ödüyoruz karşılığında ne oluyoruz onu bilip bağlama göre karar vermemiz bence önemli.
Çünkü daha önce de söylediğim gibi kalıtım inheritance tek seçeneğimiz değil.
Evet belirli sonuçları var belirli maliyetleri var belirli bağımlılıkları var onları bilmemiz gerekiyor.
Geçen dersin sonuna gidelim ve şöyle bir kod yazmıştık dedik ki böyle bir havan sınıfımız olsun bu sınıfın private elemanları olsun int ye ve arkadaşlar bu sınıfın size of değerini standart output'a yazdıralım.
Yani bir base nesnesi kaç byte yer kaplıyor bu sorunun cevabını alalım dedik ve aldık.
Benim derleyicimde 8 byte oldu çünkü int türü 4 byte dedim ki hizalama nedeniyle de özel bir durum oluşmadığı için 2 int base nesnesine 8 byte'lık bir yer ihtiyacı base nesnesi için doğuruyor.
Sonra dedik ki buraya üye fonksiyonlar ekleyelim tabi ki üye fonksiyonlar sınıf mesnesinin içinde yer almıyorlar.
Yani örneğin ben buraya 3 tane üye fonksiyonu eklesem sınıf türünün size of değerinde bir değişiklik olmayacak.
Ama buraya bir sanal fonksiyon eklediğimde görüyorsunuz f1 burada bir virtual function sınıf nesnesinin daha doğrusu sınıf türünün size of değerinin 12'ye çıktığını gördük.
Demek ki ilginç bir durum bir sanal fonksiyon geldiğinde 4 byte'lık bir artış oldu.
Sanal fonksiyon sayısını arttırıyorum.
F2'yi ve F3'ü de virtual function yapıyorum.
Ve size of değerini tekrar yazdırıyorum.
Yine bir değişiklik olmadı.
Demek ki fark şöyle bir kestirimde bulunabiliriz.
Şöyle bir çıkarımda bulunabiliriz.
Aslında o 4 byte'lık fark sınıfın polimorfik olması ya da olmaması ile ilgili.
Yani sınıf polimorfik olduğunda, polimorfik bir klas söz konusu olduğunda 4 byte'lık bir artış oldu.
Dahası izleyin sanal fonksiyonları tekrar yorum satırına alalım bildirimlerini ve kalıtım yoluyla base sınıfından her zaman yaptığımız gibi ders sınıfını elde edelim.
Ve şimdi sadece base sınıfının değil, ders sınıfının da size of değerini standart output'a yazdıralım.
O da 8.
Bir tane sanal fonksiyon ekleyelim ve hem base sınıfının hem ders sınıfının size of değerinin ikisinin birden 12'ye yükseldiğini görüyorsunuz.
Arkadaşlar.
Şimdi gelelim sadede.
Yani makro düzeyde tipik bir implementasyonun nasıl olduğunu açıklamaya çalışalım.
Ama burası biraz kafamızı karıştırabilir.
Başta da söyledim C++ standartı asla implementasyona karışmaz.
Ama hemen bütün derleyicilerin implementasyonu böyle olduğu için adeta standart gibi görülüyor.
Dolayısıyla bir mülakatta virtual dispatch nasıl implement ediliyor gibi bir soruyla karşılaşırsanız beklenen cevap şimdi size söylediğim açıklamayı gerektirecek.
Arkadaşlar sınıf polimorfik hale gelince derleyici avans sınıf nesnesinin içine bir tane pointer gömüyor.
Yani o 4 byte bir pointer elemana sahip olduğu için fazla.
Yani polimorfik sınıfların avans sınıf nesnesinin içinde bir tane pointer var.
Bu pointer'a popüler olarak arkadaşlar bu tür implementasyonlarda virtual function paper pointer deniyor.
Bazen böyle sembolik olarak VPTR, VPTR ismiyle ondan bahsediliyorlar.
Ne demek virtual function table pointer?
Hatta bazen uzun uzun böyle demek yerine virtual pointer da diyorlar.
Arkadaşlar derleyici, program çalışma zamanı, derleyicinin ürettiği kodla programın çalışma zamanında, buraya dikkat.
Kalıtım yerarşisindeki her sınıf için bir veri yapısı oluşturuyor.
Runtime'de bir veri yapısı oluşturuyor da bunu derleyicinin ürettiği kod gerçekleştiriyor.
Bu veri yapısına sanal fonksiyon tablosu anlamında virtual function table deniyor.
Bu veri yapısı şöyle bir veri yapısı.
Kafanıza canlandırın.
Mesela bakınız, diyelim ki bizim kar sınıfı.
Arkadaşlar şimdilik klon fonksiyonunu da görmezden gelin.
Diyelim ki üç tane sanal fonksiyonu var.
Yine destraktör konusunu henüz konuşmadık.
Hatta isterseniz şuraya şöyle bir not alalım.
Bizim kar sınıfımızın şöyle bir sınıfı olduğunu düşünelim.
Klas, kar, hatta küçük kartla yazayım bir yeriyle de isim çakışması oluşturmasın.
Public, virtual, world, stop.
Bunlar sanal ya da saf sanal olabilir.
Pure virtual olabilir.
Efendim start, run ve stop.
Takip etmeye çalışın.
Derleyici her bir sınıf için dedik bir sanal fonksiyon tablosu oluşturuyor.
Bu bir veri yapısı.
Tabi bu veri yapısının nasıl bir veri yapısı olduğu tamamen derleyiciye bağlı.
Tipik olarak indekse erişim constant time'da olsun diye vektörel bir veri yapısı arkadaşlar.
Hatta ben şuraya güzel bir şekil çizmeye çalıştım.
Onun üstünü de göstereyim.
O süper.
Bakın şimdi.
Her sınıf için bir sanal fonksiyon tablosu var.
Sanal fonksiyon tablosu indeksle fonksiyon adreslerine erişebileceğiniz bir veri yapısı.
Cümleyi tekrar edeyim ile indekste fonksiyon adreslerine erişebileceğimiz bir veri yapısı.
Örneğin.
Kar sınıfından Toyota, Volvo.
Benim biraz Volvo takıntım var herhalde.
Toyota, Volvo.
Fiyat sınıflarının inheritance yoluyla, kalıtım yoluyla.
Arkadaşlar kar sınıfından kalıtım yoluyla elde edildiğini düşünelim.
Toyota için bir sanal fonksiyon tablosu var.
Rampheim'de Volvo için bir sanal fonksiyon tablosu var.
Fiyat için bir sanal fonksiyon tablosu var.
Örneğin.
Tar sınıfından Opel, Dacia, Renault, Mercedes sınıfları kalıtım yoluyla elde edildiğinde
derleyicinin oluşturacağı kodla programı çalışma zamanında bu sınıfların her biri içinde bir sanal fonksiyon tablosu olacak mı?
Evet.
Peki bu sanal fonksiyon tablosu da bir şey dikkatinizi çekiyor mu?
Her bir sınıf için oluşturulan sanal fonksiyon tablosunun aynı indeksinde aynı sanal fonksiyonun adresi var.
Yani lütfen takip ediniz.
Örneğin Toyota için oluşturulmuş olan sanal fonksiyon tablosunun bir indeksinde
Toyota'nın RAM fonksiyonunun adresi,
Volvo için oluşturulmuş sanal fonksiyon tablosunun bir indeksinde
Volvo'nun RAM fonksiyonunun adresi
ve Fiat için oluşturulmuş sanal fonksiyon tablosunda Fiat'ın RAM fonksiyonunun adresi var.
O zaman derleyici compile time'da, buraya dikkat,
oluşturulacak RAM time'de oluşturulacak sanal fonksiyon tablosunun örneğin bir indeksinde
hangi sınıf olursa olsun onun sanal fonksiyon tablosunun bir indeksinde
örneğin RAM override'ının adresinin ne olacağını biliyor.
Burayı anladık mı?
Soru, her nesne başına mı bir sanal fonksiyon tablosu var yoksa her sınıf başına mı?
Cevap, her sınıf başına.
Arkadaşlar, şimdi gelelim polimorfik sınıf nesnelerine.
Mesela bu Toyota Object, Toyota nesnesi, bu Volvo nesnesi, bu Fiat nesnesi.
Bunların her birinin içinde bir taban sınıf nesnesi var değil mi?
O taban sınıf nesnesinin içinde de Virtual Function Table Pointer var değil mi?
Demin söylediğimiz o 4 baytlık farkı oluşturan bir polimorfik sınıf nesnesi oluşturulduğunda
Evet, onun Constructor'a çağrılıyor ama derleyicinin ürettiği kodla
onun taban sınıf nesnesinin içindeki Virtual Function Pointer Table
Virtual Function Table Pointer
ilgili sınıfın sanal fonksiyonunun adresini tutuyor.
Onunla initialize ediliyor.
Yani Toyota nesnesinin içindeki taban sınıf nesnesi olan
Kar sınıf nesnesinin içindeki VPTR
Toyota sınıfının sanal fonksiyon tablosunun adresini
Dacia nesnesinin içindeki
Kar nesnesinin içindeki VPTR
Dacia sınıfının sanal fonksiyon tablosunun adresini tutuyor.
Şimdi soru
Her sınıf nesnesinin içinde bir VPTR var mı?
Evet, yani sanal fonksiyon tablo pointerı her sınıf nesnesinin içinde var.
Ama sanal fonksiyon tablosu her sınıf için var.
Şimdi gelelim sonuca.
Diyelim ki arkadaşlar Kar PTR bizim geçen dersimizde yazdığımız örneklerde olduğu gibi
bir taban sınıf türünden pointer takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Ve o da siz Kar PTR ok ram biçiminde bir fonksiyon çağrısı yaptınız.
Yani Virtual Dispatch'in devreye gireceği senaryolardan biri.
Buraya kadar takip edebildik mi?
Evet.
Arkadaşlar, derleyici
Şimdi sorulara lütfen cevap vermeye çalışın.
Bugün daha hiç soru sormaya başlamadım.
Soruları sormaya başlıyorum.
Cevaplarla gelsin lütfen.
Soru
Derleyici
İsim aramayı compile time'da yapıyor değil mi?
Cevap
Kesinlikle.
Dolayısıyla derleyici
Ok operatörünün sağ operanda olan run ismini
compile time'da arıyor değil mi?
Tabii ki Kar sınıfında arayacak.
Böylece Kar sınıfı içinde bulduğu run isminin
bir Virtual Function'a ait olduğunu biliyor değil mi?
Derleyici bunu compile time'da anlıyor.
Bu bir sanal fonksiyon çağrısı.
Buraya kadar tamam mı?
Tamam.
Peki, derleyici run'ın sanal fonksiyon olduğunu anladığında
bunun için compile time'da bir indeks elde edebilir değil mi?
Yani o tablodaki indeksi aslında compile time'da elde ediyor.
Yani örneğin basitleştirerek söylüyorum.
Start'ın indeksi 0
Run'ın indeksi 1
Efendim
Stop'ın indeksi 2 gibi.
Dolayısıyla derleyici
daha burada compile time'da elde ettiği indeksle
sanal fonksiyon tablosunda kullanacağı indeksi elde etmiş oluyor.
Peki, bunu nasıl bir koda dönüştürüyor?
Sembolik olarak yazıyorum.
Karptr bir kar pointerı
Hangi türemiş sınıf nesnesinin adresini tutuyor olursa olsun
onun içindeki kar nesnesinin adresini tutuyor.
Bunu derleyici biliyor.
Arkadaşlar
Onun
Vptr elemanına erişiyor.
Böylece bu adresten neyi elde ediyor?
Sanal fonksiyon tablosunun adresini elde ediyor.
Ve compile time'da elde ettiği indeksi kullanarak
o indeksteki fonksiyon adresine erişiyor.
Ve o adresteki fonksiyonu çağırıyor.
Aslında son derece basit değil mi?
C'de de kendimizi gayet basit gerçekleştirebiliriz.
Tekrar edelim mi?
Taban sınıf pointerının gösterdiği taban sınıf nesnesinin içindeki
sanal fonksiyon tablo göstericisinin adresini elde ediyor.
Oradan indekse erişimle çağrılacak sanal fonksiyonun adresini elde ediyor.
Ve o adresteki fonksiyona çağır yapıyor.
Böyle bir kod oluşturuyor.
Dolayısıyla derleyici aslında yürettiği kodla derleme zamanında
hangi fonksiyonun çağrıldığını o da bilmiyor değil mi?
Yani burada kar ptr'nin içindeki vptr hangi sanal hangi sınıfın
sanal fonksiyon tablosunu gösteriyorsa oradaki bu indeksteki fonksiyon çağrılacak.
Şimdi böyle baktığımız zaman işte bu mülakatların meşhur sorusuna bir cevap vermeye çalışalım.
Arkadaşlar ben şimdi her iki ne diyelim uçta da yazıları çok görüyorum.
Bir uç sanal fonksiyon çağrı maliyetinin çok düşük olduğunu ciddiye almamak gerektiğini söylüyor.
Bazı senaryolarda doğru olabilir.
Bir uçta tam tersi bunun maliyetinin ciddi bir maliyet olduğunu söylüyor.
Belki duruma göre bundan vazgeçmemiz gerekebileceğini söylüyor.
Her ikisi de haklı ya da haksız olabilir.
Tamamen içinde bulunduğumuz bağlama göre.
Şimdi gerçekçi bir değerlendirme yaparsak maliyet.
Yani burada ana dili Türkçe olmayan arkadaşlar için İngilizce'deki kast veriminin Türkçesi olarak Arapçadan gelmeyi zaten kullanıyoruz.
Arkadaşlar maliyet derken bir tabii işlemsel maliyet.
Yani yapılan işlem sayısı olarak iki bir de kullanılan bellek alanı yani İngilizce karşılığıyla storage açısından maliyete bakmamız gerekiyor.
Önce işlemsel maliyete bakalım arkadaşlar.
İşlemsel maliyet bir kere iki tane ilave, iki ilave yani İngilizcesinde additional arkadaşlar dereferencing var burada açık.
İki tane ilave dereferencing var.
Nedir bu ilave dereferencing?
Bir, arkadaşlar sınıf nesnesinin içindeki VPTR'a erişmek için bir dereferencing yapıyoruz.
VPTR'a erişim yani sanal fonksiyon tablosunun adresini elde etmek için
taban sınıf nesnesinin içindeki o derleyicinin gömdüğü pointer'a erişim öyle değil mi?
Bir de bu pointer yoluyla pablo'daki fonksiyon adresine erişim.
pablo'nun belirli indeksindeki fonksiyon adresine erişim.
Yani bu fonksiyonu biz vaktan bilseydik compile time'da bu iki dereferencing olmayacaktı.
Dolayısıyla iki tane dereferencing fazlası var.
Ha şimdi şunu da söyleyebiliriz.
Öyle durumlar var ki derleyici koda bakarak statik olarak aslında virtual dispatch olması gereken kağıt üstünde senaryoda
hangi fonksiyonun çağrıldığını koda bakarak anlayabiliyor.
Bu durumda virtual dispatch kodunu elimine edip doğrudan normal bir fonksiyon çağrılır gibi falanca sınıfının falanca override'ını çağırabiliyor.
Yani bu virtual dispatch duruma göre compile time'da arkadaşlar hangi fonksiyonun çağrıldığının anlaşılması
ve virtual dispatch kodu yerine o fonksiyona doğrudan fonksiyon çağrısının İngilizcesine bind edilmesi şekline dönüşebiliyor.
De-virtualization deniyor popüler olarak bu optimizasyonu.
Bazı durumlarda derleyici bunu yapabilir.
İki tane de-referencing maliyeti var.
Ama şimdi şu maliyetleri de düşünmek gerekiyor arkadaşlar.
Dikkat.
Peki bu sanal fonksiyon tabloları runtime'da oluşturulmayacak mı?
Bunun da bir maliyeti var değil mi?
Kesinlikle.
Yani örneğin 20 tane sınıf varsa 20 tane sınıf için 20 tane veri yapısı runtime'ın başında oluşturulmak zorunda.
Bunun da bir maliyeti var ama bu maliyet bir kere ödeniyor değil mi?
Bir başka maliyet o zaman şöyle yazalım.
Sanal fonksiyon tablolarının bu da bir veri yapısı.
Arkadaşlar nasıl siz şimdi bir vektör nesnesi oluştursanız vektörün int açılımı türünden ivek ve bu vektöre belirli öğelerle başlatsanız.
İşte programı çalışma zamanında nasıl bu konteyner nesnesi oluşturuluyorsa o konteyner belirli öğeleri tutacak şekilde arkadaşlar konstruktörü çalışıyorsa burada da aynı şekilde buradaki vektörde diyelim ki o da vektör olsun.
İşte o sanal fonksiyonların adreslerinde tutuyor.
Bunun bir maliyeti var.
Dacia için ayrı.
Efendim BMW için ayrı.
Mercedes için ayrı.
Sanal fonksiyon tabloları.
Ama bu bir kere oluşturuluyor değil mi?
Tablolarının oluşturulması maliyeti.
Ama bir de şu var.
Eğer polimoripik nesne için.
Diyelim ki sizin polimoripik nesnenizin iki tane elemanı var.
Normalde konstruktör o iki elemanı initialize edecekken bir de ne initialize ediliyor arkadaşlar?
VPTR.
Ben artık VPTR derken neyi kastettiğimi biliyorsunuz.
VPTR'ın initialize edilmesi maliyeti de var.
Bunlar bir çırpada görülen maliyetler.
Kimsenin itiraz edemeyeceği.
Sizin için önem taşır ya da taşımaz.
Birçok uygulamada iki tane dereferensink benim umrumda değil diyebilirsiniz.
Yani virtual dispatch'ten kazandığınız oradaki iki tane dereferensinkten arkadaşlar açınmanızı gerektirecek.
bir ne diyelim maliyet değildir.
Yani bunu bilerek isteyerek harcarsınız elde ettiğiniz getiriyle oranlı olarak.
Ama bence şunu da düşünmek gerekiyor.
Bence asıl problematik taraf bu iki tane dereferensink değil.
Ya da VPTR'ın initialize edilmesi değil.
ya da virtual function table'ların oluşturulması değil.
Bence asıl düşünülmesi gereken maliyetlerden biri
virtual dispatch'in sizi hemen her zaman dinamik ömürlü nesne oluşturmaya yöneltmesi.
onu neredeyse zorunlu hale getirmek, getirmesi.
Dikkat!
Çok büyük çoğunlukla, bunun dışında kalan senaryolar mutlaka vardır.
Çok büyük çoğunlukla
virtual dispatch
dinamik ömürlü
nesneleri gerektiriyor.
Yani bu ne demek?
Mesela gerçekten car game
diye bir oyun olsaydı
hep verdiğimiz örnek ki
bugün de o
doğrultuda örnekler vereceğim.
Cengiz Han Bey diyor ki
Ayrıca Yüz'e derleyici virtual fonksiyonların
hangi kodun çağrılacağını
compile time'da bilemeyeceği için
bazı optimizasyonları yapamaması da
olumsuz yönleri arasında sayabileceğimiz bir konu değil mi?
Kesinlikle çok haklı Cengiz Han.
Kesinlikle.
Arkadaşlar bu
Cengiz Han Bey'in söylediği durum
normal fonksiyonlar için de geçerli.
Yani örneğin bir fonksiyonu siz
bir function pointer ile çağırın
bir de fonksiyonu ismiyle çağırın.
Arada çok büyük bir fark var
basit gibi görünseli.
Fonksiyonu siz ismiyle çağırdığınız zaman
yani hangi fonksiyonun
çağrıldığını derleyici bildiği zaman
çağrılan fonksiyonun da kodunu gördüğünde
ne yapabiliyor?
Inline Expansion yapabiliyor.
En önemli optimizasyonlardan biri.
Inline Expansion daha önce konuşmuştuk.
Ama siz
diyelim ki PPTR bir fonksiyon göstericisi.
Siz PPTR'nin gösterdiği fonksiyonu
çağırırsanız
derleyici
PPTR'nin değerinin
hangi fonksiyonun adresi olduğunu
bilemeyeceğine göre
ki çok büyük çoğunlukla bilemeyecek
burada
arkadaşlar
çağrıldığı noktada
çağrılan fonksiyonun
kodunu görmesi bilmesi söz konusu değil.
Aslında en önemli optimizasyon
bu Inline Expansion kısmı.
Yani derleyici eğer burada
hangi fonksiyonun çağrıldığını
bilseydi
fonksiyon çağrısının
üstündeki kodlarla fonksiyon çağrısının
altındaki kodları
bir bütün olarak ele alıp
burada ilave optimizasyonlar da
yapabilecekti.
Yani Cengiz Han Bey bu konuda da
haklı kesinlikle.
Ama
buna ilaveten
yani ona yüzde yüz katılıyorum
düşünmemiz gereken
önemli bir noktada
tam onu anlatıyordum
Cengiz Han Bey'in yazısı geldi.
Çok büyük çoğunlukla
Virtual Dispatch'in
dinamik ömürlü nesneleri
geriktirmesi.
Yani eğer
Virtual Dispatch örneğin
uygulamasaydık
belki de biz
otomatik ömürlü nesneler
kullanacaktık.
Ama bu senaryolarda
hemen her zaman
dinamik ömürlü nesneler
oluşturuyor.
Arkadaşlar
dinamik ömürlü nesnelerin
ilave maliyetleri var.
Şimdi
C kodu olduğunu düşünün.
Siz
dinamik ömürlü nesnenin
yerini
yani
storage'ını
işte
CEO olsaydı
özel başka bir
allocator kullanmıyorsanız
neyle elde ediyorsunuz?
Mallog
Callog
Reallog
gibi
bir fonksiyonla
elde ediyorsunuz.
Şimdi
Mallog'un
çalışma zamanında
bir maliyeti var.
Bu
hem bir işlem maliyeti
hem de
heap'ten bir
yer allocate
ediyorsunuz.
Ve
unutmayın ki
ister
Mallog olsun
Operator
New
olsun
siz
ver bana
40 byte
bellek alanı
dediğinizde
aslında
gerçek allocation
40 byte
değil.
size verilen
kısmı
bir de onun
bir header
kısmı var.
Yani bu
dynamic
allocation'ları
takip eden
veri yapısında
kullanılmak üzere
hem bir
işlemsel maliyeti var
hem de
kullanılan bir
bellek alanı var.
Öyle değil mi?
Mesela
bağlı listeler
neden
birçok senaryoda
tercih edilmiyor
ya da
kağıt üstünde
daha iyi
görünmesine rağmen
aslında
vektörer bir
veri yapısı
link listlere
outperform
edebiliyor.
Benzer
nedenlerden.
Çünkü o
bağlı listeye
her
node eklediğinizde
bir
allocation
olacak.
O
allocation'ın
bir maliyeti
var.
Arkadaşlar
hem
node'un
içinde
tuttuğunuz
pointer'ların
maliyeti
var.
Hem de
siz bir
node
oluşturduğunuzda
sadece
o node
için
değil
o dinamik
ömürlü
nesnelerin
dinamik ömürlü
nesneler için
allocate edilen
bellek alanların
hesabını
kitabını
tutmak için
bir de onun
header kısmı var.
Aynı zamanda
tabii ki
dinamik ömürlü
nesneler için
ayrılan
bellek alanının
geri verilmesi
delete edilmesi
sırasında
delete etmek
ne demek?
Arkadaşlar
hem destructor
çağrılacak ama
hem de
allocate edilen
bellek bloğu
geri verecek
onun da
runtime'da
bir maliyeti
var.
O bellek
alanı bulunacak
vesaire
vesaire.
Dolayısıyla
dinamik ömürlü
nesnelerle
bunların
gerçekleştirilmesi
o dinamik
ömürlü
nesneler için
yapılan
allocation
ve
de allocation
işlemlerinin
maliyeti
demek
aynı zamanda.
Şimdi
o zaman
işlem maliyeti
ciddiye
alınır mı
alınmaz mı
işte siz
karar verin
bulunduğunuz
ortama göre
artısıyla
eksisiyle
sizin değerlendirmeniz
gerekiyor.
Bunu şunun için
söylüyorum
burası sizin için
bir darboğaz
oluşturuyorsa
o zaman
arkadaşlar
ne yapmanız
gerekiyor?
Belki başka
yollara
başvurmanız
gerekiyor ki
gerçekten
bazı durumlarda
bazı
başka yöntemler
çok daha
efektif
olabiliyor.
Mesela
kapalı bir
sınıf
hiyerarşisi
varsa
ben bunu çok
görüyorum.
Bakın mesela
diyelim ki
bizim araba
oyunumuz
şöyle olsaydı
yani
expansion
istemiyoruz
genişleme
10 tane
20 tane
araba yok
arkadaşlar
ya da o
document örneğinde
3 onlarca
farklı
döküman
oluşturulmayacak
sonra genişleme
istenmiyor
yani baştan
3 tane
döküman var
exer
pdf
efendim
word
ya da burada
4 tane araba var
arkadaşlar
bu durumda
union
kullanmak
tabii union'ın
ehlileştirilmiş
şekli
stud variant
sınıfını
kullanmak
çok daha
efektif
olabiliyor
ya da
duruma göre
yine
eğer bunları
ortak özellikleriyle
bir konteynerda
tutmayacaksanız
belki
CRTP
paternini
örüntüsünü
tekniğini
kullanmak
daha iyi bir yol
olabilir.
Benlik maliyetine
gelince
her
polimorfik
nesne
bir pointer
büyüyor.
Arkadaşlar
bu da az şey
değil.
Yani
duruma göre
bu sizi
zorlayabilir
çalıştığınız
sistemde.
Mesela
düşünün
normalde
sizin nesneleriniz
zaten kendisi
4 byte
ama
sırf
bu
virtual dispatch
için
içinde
bir pointer
daha var
8 byte'a
çıkıyor.
bir de
dinamik olarak
allocate ediyorsunuz
bir de onun
header kısmı
geliyor.
Dolayısıyla
her nesne için
bir pointer
fazla
bellek alanına
ihtiyacınız var.
Her sınıf
içinde
o sanal fonksiyon
tablosu
arkadaşlar
bellekte
onun da
bir yere
ihtiyacı var
değil mi?
Her sınıf için
o sanal fonksiyon
tablosu
bir yer
kaplayacak.
Ama tipik olarak
implementasyon
dediğim gibi
yani ortada
bir büyü
falan yok
değil mi?
Şöyle tekrar
edersek
arkadaşlar
siz
kar ptr
ok
run
ya da
referans
emandi
de olabilir
tabii
böyle bir fonksiyon
çağrısı
yaptığımızda
aslında
gerçekte olan ne?
Bu pointer'ın
gösterdiği
kar nesnesi
içindeki
sanal fonksiyon
tablosundan
önce
vptr'ye
eriş
sonra
onun vasıtası
sanal fonksiyon
tablosundaki
belirli bir
indeksteki
fonksiyon
adresine
eriş.
Aslında ilginç
bir şekilde
şimdi söyleyeceğim
cümleyi
saptamayı
şöyle
2-3 ders sonra
size bir soru
olarak soracağım
bakalım hatırlayacak
mısınız?
Arkadaşlar
çok önemli
duruma göre
sayılabilecek
araçlardan
biri de
RTTI
bu da bizim
şimdi kalıgım
konusunda
ilerleyen
derslerde
bir alt başlığımız
olacak
RTTI
bir popüler
kısaltma
Runtime
Type
Information
ya da
Runtime
Type
Identification
oradan kısaltma
yani programın
çalışma zamanında
arkadaşlar
türün
ne olduğunun
belirlenmesi
daha önce
bundan biraz
bahsetmiştim
şimdi şöyle bir
senaryo olduğunu
düşünün
bizim yine
altın çizmesine
bakmayın
ya da şuraya
yazayım
bizim yine
bir
arkadaşlar
hiyerarşimiz var
ve şu meşhur
car game
fonksiyonumuz var
ve bu fonksiyonun
parametresi
bir car pointerı
ya da referansı
ve şimdi
şu sorunun
cevabını
arıyoruz
programın
çalışma zamanında
buraya gelen
arabanın
örneğin
bir
Mercedes
olup olmadığını
sınamamız
gerekiyor
yani nesnenin
dinamik
türünü
anlamamız
gerekiyor
yoksa
yıldız P
statik tür olarak
baktığımız zaman
yani
derlecin yaptığı
kontrollere
konu
tür olarak
baktığımız zaman
bu car türünden
bir nesne
ama
davranışa esas
tür olarak
baktığımızda
yani
eğer
car polimorfik
ve sınıfsa
yıldız P
runtime'da
Dacia'da
olabilir
Renault'da
Mercedes'de
olabilir
diyelim
mecbur
kaldığımız için
bizim şöyle bir
kontrole ihtiyacımız
var
buraya gelen
adres
bir
Mercedes
nesnesi
adresi
mi
eğer
bu da ne demek
buraya gelen bir
Mercedes mi
runtime'da
buraya gelen bir
Mercedes ise
ondan emin olup
onun
Mercedes olduğuna
runtime'da
güvenerek
onun
Mercedes olduğu
güvencesine
elde ederek
onu Mercedes olarak
kullanıp
o Mercedes'e
özel bazı
işlemleri
yapmak istiyoruz
şimdi diyeceksiniz ki
haklı olarak
Necati bu
iyi bir teknik mi
şüphesiz değil
yani
virtual dispatch'in
runtime
polimorfizminin
avantajını
aslında bir yerde
çiğnemiş
oluyorsunuz
onu
göz ardı
etmiş
oluyorsunuz
ama öyle
senaryolar var ki
bunu yapmak
zorunda
kalabiliyoruz
işte
bunu
sınamaya yönelik
araç setine
popüler olarak
RTTI deniyor
runtime type
identification
ve burada
yine
gelecekte
yakın gelecekte
göreceğimiz bir
konu
iki tane
operatör var
bu operatörler
dynamic cast
operatörü
ve
type ID
operatörü
yani
gerçekten
polimorfik bir
nesnenin
gerçek
dinamik
türünün
ne olduğunu
anlayabilmemiz
için
C++
dili
standart olarak
bize
iki tane
operatör veriyor
ama neden
şimdi bundan
bahsediyorum
o konuya
geldiğimizde
şu
bu bir
mülakatta da
soruluyor
olabilir
tipik olarak
şunu da
öğrenmek
isteyeceğiz
ya da
mülakatta
bizim
şu da
sorulacak
peki
runtime'da
nasıl
anlaşılıyor
yani
buraya
gelen
nesnenin
Mercedes
olup olmadığı
nasıl anlaşılabilir
bir düşünün
yani
bunu anlamanın
bir yolu
olmalı
değil mi
işte
neden
buraya
atıfta
bulunduğumu
şimdi anlayacaksınız
bunu anlamanın
yoluyla
aslında
virtual dispatch
mekanizmasının
yolu
aynı
yani yine
sanal fonksiyon
tablosundan
bahsedi
faydalanılıyor
arkadaşlar
yani şöyle
olduğunu düşünün
şimdi buraya
yine geri dönelim
aslında
bu tablonun
belirli bir
indeksinin
tipik olarak
diyelim ki
sıfır
indeksinin
bu amaçla
kullanıldığını
düşünelim
ve
arkadaşlar
bu
indekste de
nesnenin
dinamik türünün
ne olduğunun
anlaşılması
için
kullanılacak
örneğin
bir
nesnenin
adresi
bulunsun
gerçekten de
standart
kütüphanenin
type info
isimli bir
sınıfı var
işte burada da
o type info
nesnesinin
adresinin
olduğunu düşünelim
o adres yoluyla
o sınıfa
ilişkin
o sınıfın
kimliğini gösteren
bir sınıf
nesnesine
erişebiliyorum
yani
özetle
runtime type
identification
da
aslında yine
sanal fonksiyon
tablosunu
kullanıyor
diyebiliriz
peki
işte günahıyla
sevabıyla
bizim
virtual dispatch'imiz
tipik olarak
böyle
implemente ediliyor
dedik
şimdi bunu
belki ileride
geri dönmek
üzere
şimdilik
bir kenara
bırakalım
ve
şu
runtime
polimorfizmiyle
ilgili
geçen derslerde
görmediğimiz
birkaç tane
daha önemli
duruma
kurala
değinelim
bugün itibariyle
virtual dispatch
konusunu da
bitirmiş
olalım
yani
bu önümüzdeki
birkaç ders içinde
kalıtım
konusunu
tamamen
bitireceğim
buna
ne de dahil
private kalıtımı
protected kalıtımı
ve
arkadaşlar
multiple
inheritance
çoklu kalıtım
dahil
virtual dispatch
dışında
bir de
virtual
sözcüğünün
kullanıldığı
bir bağlam daha var
virtual inheritance
bütün bunları
göreceğiz
ondan sonra
çok önemli bir
yine
konumuz
söz konusu
olacak
bu konuda
exception handling
çok erteledik
ama ertelememin
bir nedeni daha vardı
neden bu kadar
önemli bir araca
şimdiye kadar hiç
değinmedik
sadece
bir iki küçük
gönderme yaptık
arkadaşlar
exception handling
araçları da
çoğunlukla
inheritance'ı
ve
runtime
polymorphizmini
kullanıyor
özellikle
standart
kütüphanenin
exception
hiyerarşisi
burayı
öğrendiğimiz zaman
bu runtime
polymorphizmi
kalıtım
vesaire
neyi anlamamız
biraz daha kolay
olacak
exception handling
konusunu anlamamız
biraz daha kolay
olacak
ama
sırada
küçük bir alt
başlığımız var
hemen
başlığımızı
atalım
variant
return
pipe
ya da
bir diğer
popüler bir terim
covariance
nitelici olarak
şimdi
sanal
fonksiyon
larda
yani virtual
fonksiyon
larda
hatırlayın
şöyle bir
kuralımız vardı
eğer bir
sanatın
virtual
fonksiyon
ya da
pure
virtual
fonksiyon
varsa
class
base
public
diyelim ki
int
virtual
bu
int
diyelim ki
böyle bir
sanal
fonksiyon var
bunu bir
türemiz sınıfın
override
etmesi için
ismi aynı
imzası
aynı
ama
geri dönüş
değeri
türü de
aynı
bir fonksiyon
bildirmesi
gerekiyordu
eğer
imza
farklıysa
zaten
override
olamaz
değil mi
ama
imzası
aynı
geri dönüş
değeri
türü
farklı bir
fonksiyon
bildirmesi
aynı zamanda
sentaks
hatası
eğer
fonksiyon
virtual
ise
ne demek
istiyorum
orayı da
hatırlatmak
istiyorum
araya zaman
girdiği için
unutmuş
olabiliriz
örneğin
base sınıfından
public
kalıtımıyla
ders sınıfını
elde etmiş
olalım
şimdi
eski
öğrendiklerimizi
bir hatırlayalım
eğer şöyle
yazarsam
int
bu
yukarıdaki
sanal
fonksiyonun
override
buraya
virtual
keyword'ünü
koyun ya da
koymayın
bu da bir
sanal
fonksiyon
bunu konuşmuştur
yani buraya
virtual
anahtar
sözcüğünü
yazmanızla
yazmamamız
arasında
bir fark
yok
evet
ama dedik ki
modern C++'la
birlikte
asla
böyle yazmayın
amacınız
bir sanal
fonksiyonu
override
etmekse
modern C++'la
eklenen
bir de yeni
statü vardı
ondan da
bahsettik
neydi yeni
statü
contextual
keywords
iki tane
contextual
keyword'ümüz
vardı
bir
override
diğer
final
final'da
Allah kısmet ederse
bugün
göreceğiz
yani artık
doğrusu
güzeli
iyisi
override
contextual
keyword'ünü
kullanmak
arkadaşlar
evet
ama
hatırlayın
örneğin şöyle
olsaydı
arkadaşlar
bu ayrı bir
fonksiyon
yukarıdaki fonksiyonun
override'ı
değil
kaldı ki
override
keyword'ünü
yazsaydım
syntax hatası
olacaktı
ama
eğer
imza
aynıysa
arkadaşlar
fakat
geri dönüş
değeri
türü
farklıysa
bu durumda
override
keyword'ünü
kullanmasanız da
bu
syntax hatası
yani böyle bir
fonksiyonun
bildirme hakkınız
yok
is not
covariant
from
base
book
yani diyor ki
arkadaşlar
sen bunu override
etmeye çalışıyorsun
ama geri dönüş
değeri
türünü
farklı yazmışsın
o intgen sen float
yazmışsın
ve bu bir
covariant da değil
hani diyor
covariant olsa
dilin kurallarına
uyacak
işte
buradaki
covariantın
ne olduğunu
şimdi konuşacağız
arkadaşlar
covariant
bu
türemiz sınıfın
taban sınıfın
sanal fonksiyonunu
override etmesine
rağmen
taban sınıfın
sanal fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş
değeri
türünü
farklı
yapabilmesi
seçeneğine
ilişkin
bir
istisna
nasıl bir cümle
oldu
yani öyle bir
istisna var ki
taban sınıfın
sanal fonksiyonunu
override ederken
biz fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş
değeri
türünü
farklı yazıyoruz
ama yine
sentaks hatası
olmuyor
ve o
yine bir
override
oluyor
işte
buna yönelik
bir
istisna
arkadaşlar
şimdi
başlangıçta
biraz karmaşık
gelebilir
hem
sentaks tarafı
hem de
varlık nedeni
hemen anlaşılmayabilir
ama bir
açıklayalım
diyelim ki
bir sınıf var
B sınıfı
ve B sınıfından
kalıtım yoluyla
elde edilmiş
bir
D sınıfı var
ve
public kalıtı mı
yani
class
B
public
şimdi
önce şunu bir
hatırlayalım
bu
public kalıtı mı
olduğuna göre
runtime
polimortizmi
olsun
ya da
olmasın
bu
public kalıtı mı
olduğuna göre
her
B nesnesi
aynı zamanda
bir
B nesnesidir
değil mi
cevap
evet
şimdi
bunlar yukarıda
kalsın
yine biz
bir
taban sınıfı
oluşturalım
ve taban sınıfımızın
bir sanal fonksiyonu
olsun
taban sınıfı
sınıfımızın
sanal fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş
değeri
B
yıldız olsun
yani
pointer to
B
olsun
bu
sanal fonksiyona
Foo ismini
verelim
ve
virtual
function
olsun
yine benzer
şekilde
yine
kuralı
göstermek
için
bir sanal
fonksiyonu
daha koyalım
taban sınıfa
bunun geri dönüş
değeri de
B
R
olsun
şimdi
sıkı durun
normalde
base'den
kalıtım
yoluyla elde edilecek
der gibi
bir sınıfın
sanal
Foo
ya da sanal
bar fonksiyonlarını
override etmesi için
az önce konuştuğumuz üzere
override'in geri dönüş
değeri türünün de
B
star
ya da
B ref olması
lazım
değil mi
evet
mesela bakın
class
der
public
arkadaşlar
base
şimdi override
ediyorum
public
geri dönüş değeri
B
yıldız
bu
hatta
override'ı da koyayım ki
eğer override olmasaydı
sentax hatası
olacaktı
bir sentax hatası
yok
aynı şekilde
bar fonksiyonunu
override
ediyorum
ve
B
ref
döndürüyorum
bu zaten
şimdiye kadar
öğrendiğimiz
kural
ama şimdi
bakın
der sınıfı
B sınıfının
full fonksiyonunu
override
ederken
B yıldız
yerine
D yıldız
döndürsün
yine
bar fonksiyonunu
override
ederken
B ref
yerine
D ref
döndürsün
bir sentax
hatası
olmadığını
görüyorsunuz
işte
covariant
diye buna
dönüyor
yani bir sınıfın
sanal fonksiyonu
arkadaşlar
bir taban sınıf
türünden
pointer
ya da taban sınıf
türünden
referans
döndürüyorsa
pointer
döndürmesi
full fonksiyonundaki
durum
referans
döndürmesi
bar fonksiyonundaki
durum
türemiz sınıf
bunu
override
ederken
B yıldız
yerine
B'nin
bir
child
kılası
yani
B'den
kalıtım yoluyla
elde edilmiş
public
kalıtım yoluyla
elde edilmiş
örneğin
D sınıfı
türünden
adres
döndürebilir
çünkü o da
her D bir
B olduğuna
göre
bu fonksiyon
B yıldız
döndürüyor
o da diyor ki
D yıldız
döndürüyorum
ben
ne de olsa
diyor
D de bir
B'dir
pointer
semantiyeli
ya da referans
bunu yapabiliyorsunuz
daha ne faydası
alacak ona
değinmedim
ama anlaşıldı
değil mi
bakın gerçekten
böyle bir
kural olmasaydı
bu
sentax hatası
oldurdu
çünkü hem
override
hem de
geri dönüş
değeri
türü
farklı
ama işte
cover
burdens
olduğu için
bir
sentax
hatası
oluşmadı
yalnız
bir şeye
dikkat
bunun
olması
için
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değerinin
pointer
ya da
referans
olması
gerekiyor
mesela
yine
alan sınıfın
boom
isimli bir fonksiyonu
olsaydı
bazı yerine
artık
boom
kullanıyorum
isimli bir
sanal fonksiyonu
olsaydı
bu fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
B türü
olsaydı
bakın
B yıldız
değil
B ref de
B türü
ve
bu da
sanal bir fonksiyon
olsaydı
şimdi
der sınıfı
boom'u
override
ederken
B'ye döndürmek
yerine
D'ye döndürebilir
miydi
bu
covariance
kabul edilecek
mi
hayır
yani
türün kendisi
covariance
kabul edilmiyor
ya pointer
ya da referans
sematiye söz konusu
olması lazım
yine de
deneyelim
sanki
covariance
gibi
boom'u
override
edelim
ama
boom'u
override
ederken
geri dönüş
değerini
B yapalım
bakın az önceki
kodlar
derleniyordu
şimdi bunu
yaptığımda
derliyorum
derleyicimin
verdiği
hata mesajını
okuyorum
diyor ki
derin boom'u
overriding
virtual function
return type
difference
and it's not
covariance
from base
bomb
yani ilk verdiği
hata mesajını
verdi
demek ki
bu covariant
kabul edilmiyor
anlaşıldı
değil mi
o zaman
covariant
son derece
basit
taban sınıf
geri dönüş
değeri olarak
evet object slicing
olduğu için
Cengiz Han
bu doğrudan
satarsataz
yani bunun
override
kabul edilmiyor
covariant
taban sınıf
sanal fonksiyonunda
bir sınıf
türünden
adres
ya da referans
döndürüyorsa
türemiz sınıf
onu override
ederken
taban sınıfın
geri döndürdüğü
adres
ya da pointer'a
ilişkin sınıfın
bir child sınıfı
yani ondan
kalıtım yoluyla
elde edilmiş
easy relationship
olan
bir sınıf türünden
pointer
ne yapabilir
ya da referans
döndürebilir
arkadaşlar bunun nedeni ne
şimdi onu konuşalım
aslında son derece
basit bir nedeni var
hayır
int olamazdır
o sürü
niçin
e çünkü
int kalıtımla
ilgili değil ki
orayı kaçırmış
olabilir misiniz
önce rasyonun
sorusuna cevap vereyim
yani şöyle olsaydı
artık burada
kovaryans olma
ihtimali
olur muydu
hayır
çünkü
ancak
şöyle bir durum
olması lazım
değil mi
int'den kalıtım
yoluyla elde edilen
bir sınıf türünden
pointer döndürecek
ama int bir sınıf
değil ki
dolayısıyla
int sınıfından
kalıtım yoluyla
elde edilmiş
bir sınıf gibi
bir ihtimali
olmadığı için
artık burada
kovaryans ihtimali
yok
anlaşıldı mı
önemli olan
anlaşılması
arkadaşlar
bakın şimdi
çok çok
dikkatli izliyorsunuz
aslında
bakalım kaç kişi
hatırlayacak
ses tonuma
dramatik bir
hava vermeye
çalışayım
bakalım
kaç kişi
hatırlayacak
bizim geçen
derste yazdığımız
bir örnek vardı
hatırlıyor musunuz
ben
konstruktör
sanal
olamaz
c++
dilinde
virtual
konstruktör
yok
ama c++'mızda da
virtual
konstruktör
idiom var
demiştim
hatırlıyor musunuz
o idioma da
klon idiomu
dendiğini
söylemiştim
şimdi
sadece
benim gösterdiğim
yere bakın
ve bir şey
dikkatinizi
çekiyor mu
avans sınıfın
klon fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş
değeri ne
kar yıldız
normalde biz
geçen
derste yazdığımız
kodda
mercedes
klon fonksiyonunu
override ederken
arkadaşlar
mercedes
kar yıldız
döndürmüştü
değil mi
peki şimdi
söyleyin bakalım
mercedes'in
klon override'ının
kar yıldız
yerine
mercedes
yıldız
döndürebilmesi
kovaryastan
başka bir şey
değil
değil mi
burayı
gördüğünüzden
emin olunuz
ve
evet anlaşıldı
kesinlikle aynı şey
diyorsanız
arkadaşlar
şöyle diyormuşum
bir like atın
bir like atmayın
ama
anladığınızı
en azından
bir arkadaşım
belirtirse
arkadaşlar
demin anlattığımdan
aslında
hiçbir farkı
yok
değil mi
düşünsenize
normalde
klonu
benim override
etmem için
benim
mercedes'imin
klon override'ının
da bravo
olam bravo
olsan
kar yıldız
döndürmesi
gerekiyor
ama bakın
mercedes'in
klonu
mercedes
yıldız döndürüyor
reno'nun klonu
reno yıldız
döndürüyor
fiyatın
klonu
fiyat yıldız
döndürüyor
volvo'nun
klonu
arkadaşlar
volvo yıldız
döndürüyor
ve bir
sentaks hatası
olmuyor
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
evet
bir sentaks hatası
olmuyor
çünkü
bu da yine
ne
bir
törenin
covariance
hikayesi
başka bir şey
değil
ama şimdi
covariance'ı
neden
ihtiyaç duyuluyor
aslında
hem bizim
klon örneğimiz
bunu çok güzel
gösterebilir
ama
klon örneği
göstermese de
az önceki
kodda bile
gösterebilirim
şu
bunu
silelim
arkadaşlar
şimdi
söyleyin
mesela
ben
b sınıfının
full fonksiyonuna
çağrı yapsam
geri dönüş
ve geri dönüş
değerini
b yıldız
türünden
bir nesnede
tutacağım
ama ben şunu
da yapabilirim
bakınız
ders sınıfının
şimdi
covariance'ı
kullanmayalım
bunu
b yıldız
yapalım
bunu da
b ref yapalım
biraz karmaşık gibi
gelecek ama
lütfen
ipin ucunu
kaçırdığınızda
tekrar etmemi
isteyin
şu anda
covariance kullanmıyorum
yani ilk
öğrendiğimiz
gibi
peki
mesela
arkadaşlar
şöyle olsaydı
void
bu
base yıldız
base ptr
ve ben
bu fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş
değerini
bir pointer
tutsaydım
base ptr
ok
bu
tabi ki
geri dönüş
değerini
base yıldızda
tutacağım
zaten bu fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri de
b yıldızda
özür dilerim
tutacağım
b yıldız
bt
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
burada herhangi bir
sorun yok
belki bu
b'ye döndürüyor
arkadaşlar
takip edebiliyor muyuz
belki
d'ye döndürüyor
çünkü
bunların arasında
kalıtım ilişkisi var
ama şimdi
konu şöyle olduğunu
düşünün
elimde zaten
bir
der mesnesi var
der mayder
ve ben
mayder'in
full fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
peki mayder'in
full fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş
değerinin
ben
aslında
d yıldız
olduğunu biliyorsam
yani bu fonksiyonu
aslında
d yıldız
döndürüyorsa
yine de
şöyle yapmak
zorundayım
değil mi
eğer şöyle yazarsam
d yıldız
d p
eşittir mayder'in
full'su
şimdi
sentaks hatası
olur
aslında ben
atak
şöyle göstereyim ki
diyorum
aslında
bu fonksiyon
diyelim ki
d adresi
döndürüyor
döndürmesine
rağmen
ben bunu
d pointer'ında
bu şekilde
tutamıyorum
çünkü burada
downcasting var
taban sınıftan
primi sınıfa
dönüşüm var
türemiş sınıftan
taban sınıfa
değil
dolayısıyla
bu kodun
legal olması
için
ben şimdi
arkadaşlar
statik
kest
bildiğim için
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
diyelim
normalde
d adresi
olduğunu
statik
kest
operatörüyle
d yıldız
buraya dikkat
dynamic
kesti
d yıldız
türüne
kesti edeceğim
ve ancak
kodu böyle
yazarsam
legal olacak
ama
şimdi
eğer bu
b yıldız
yerine
d yıldız
döndürseydi
buna hiç
gerek kalmayacaktı
ben kodu
doğrudan
böyle yazabilecektim
bu örnek
derken
mydenin
full su biçiminde
yazabilecektim
bu örnek
kafanızı
karıştırmışsa
bizim
klon örneği
son derece
açık
bakın şimdi
karmaşlık
dosyasını
dahil edeyim
include
k.h
karmaşlık
dosyasını
dahil ettim
ve şimdi
elimde
zaten
benim
bir
ne olsun
reno
ne istemi
olsun
reno
re
ve şimdi
ben
re'nin
klon fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
arkadaşlar
re'nin klon fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
reno
yıldız döndürüyor
ama şimdi
kar yıldız
döndürseydi
yani
kovaryans
kullanılmasaydı
ben şöyle
yazsaydım
reno
yıldız
rp
eşittir
re'nin klonu
sandak
sepası
olacaktı
bunu legal
kılmak için
kür dönüştürme
operatörünü
kullanacaktım
ama şimdi
diyorum ki
hayır
reno'nun klonu
reno
pointer'ı
döndürüyor
o zaman
doğrudan
bu bir
sandak
sapası
olmayacak
yani bu tür
senaryolarda
yazımı
kolaylaştırıyor
gereksiz
tür dönüşümlerini
elimine etmiş
oluyoruz
işte en güzel örneği
oraya tekrar
geleyim ki
anladığınızdan
emin olun
arkadaşlar
buradaki
klon fonksiyonu
taban sınıfta
geri dönüşleri
kar yıldız
ama her bir sınıf
bunu override
ederken
kendi sınıfa
türünden
adres döndürüyor
çünkü
her mercedes
bir kar olduğu için
covariance'dan
faydalanabiliyorum
arkadaşlar bu arada
bakın bir şey
daha göstermek istiyorum
şimdi az önce
sanal fonksiyon
tablosundan
virtual dispatch'in
nasıl implement
edildiğinden
bahsettim ya
burada bir şeye
daha dikkat
çekmek istiyorum
multi-level inheritance
olduğunda
ben buraya özellikle
multi-level inheritance
da ekledim
şöyle ki
bakın
bir Volvo sınıfı var
Volvo sınıfı
public kalıtımıyla
kar sınıfından
elde edilmiş
bir de
Volvo
Türkçe okuyorum
XC90
sınıfı var
o da
Volvo sınıfından
kalıtım yoluyla
elde edilmiş
yani her
Volvo bir
arabadır
ama her
Volvo
XC90
da bir
Volvo
burada dikkat ederseniz
XC90
da
arkadaşlar
klon fonksiyonunu
ne yapmış
implemente etmiş
override etmiş
yine
start run
stop fonksiyonlarını
override etmiş
burada
geçen size
arkadaşlar
yaptığım uyarı
gereği
burada
her biri de
düzelteceğim
ben de başka bir yerden
kopyalım
override'lara
eklememiz gerekiyor
takip edebiliyor muyuz
şimdi soru
Volvo XC90'ın da
bir sanal fonksiyon
tablosu olacak mı
olacak
peki
Volvo XC90
klonu override
etmeseydi
takip edebiliyor muyuz
arkadaşlar
klonu override
etmeseydi
o zaman
Volvo XC90
için
kimin fonksiyonu
çağrılacaktı
tabi ki
Volvo'nun fonksiyonu
çağrılacaktı
Volvo'u da override
etmeseydi
tabi eğer
car sınıfı
arkadaşlar
abstract sınıfı
olmasaydı
car'ın
ya da bunlar
pure virtual function
değil virtual function
olsaydı
car sınıfının
efendim
start fonksiyonu
çağrılacaktı
bakın bakın
bunu göstermek için
şöyle bir şey yapalım
izleyin
create random car
fonksiyonu
fonksiyonunda
bir değişiklik yaptım
Volvo XC90'da
döndürüyor
ve şimdi
main fonksiyonu
içinde
bir döngü
döngünün içinde
create random car'ı
çağırıyorum
car yıldız
döndürüyor
arkadaşlar
ve
buradaki
car game fonksiyonu
koymuş muyuz
hadi car game fonksiyonu
buraya yazalım
void
car game
parametresi
kar yıldız
p
işte az önceki
ya da geçen
haftaki örnek
önce start fonksiyonu
run fonksiyonu
start fonksiyonu
çağrılmış olsun
buraya da bir
get car çağrısı
koyalım
fonksiyonu
argüman olarak
gönderelim
car game
e
dinamik ömürlüğü
nesnemesi
delete edelim
birazdan konumuz
bu olacak
ve
run type'a
bakalım
ve bir
Volvo XC90
gelmesini
bekleyelim
adi
evet
bakın
Volvo XC90
geldiğinde
Volvo XC90'ın
startı
runı
Volvo XC90'ın
stop'ı
çağrıldı
gerçi tabi biz
hangi
nesnenin
oluşturulduğunu
yazdırmadık
ama
en azından
Volvo XC90'ın
karşımıza çıktığını
en az bir kere
görüyorsunuz
ama şimdi
şöyle yapalım
göstermek için
Volvo XC90
fonksiyonlardan
birini
override etmesin
örneğin
arkadaşlar
stop fonksiyonunu
override etmesin
bunu yorum
satırına
aldım
ve
tekrar
arkadaşlar
derleyip
çalıştırıyorum
ve
şunu da
kapatalım
ve
Volvo XC90
gelmesini
bekleyelim
belki hemen
gelir
evet
bakın
gayet güzel
gördük
şimdi
Volvo XC90
gelmiş
argain
fonksiyonuna
stop fonksiyonuna
stop fonksiyonu
onun override'ı
run fonksiyonu
ama stop fonksiyonu
Volvo'nun override'ı
yani eğer ben
taban sınıfın
sanal fonksiyonunu
override etmezsem
trimis sınıfı
taban sınıfı
sanal fonksiyonu
override etmezse
orada taban sınıfınki
çağrılıyor
orayı anladık değil mi
bu da aslında
implementasyon tarafında
ne demek
Volvo XC90'ın
sanal fonksiyonu
tablosunda
o indeksinde
normalde override'ı
override etseydi
Volvo XC90'ın
stop fonksiyonunun
adresi olacaktı
ama orada
o indekste
Volvo XC90'ın
sanal
override'ın
adresi değil
taban sınıfının
yani
Volvo'nun
stop fonksiyonunun
adresi var
anlaşıldı mı?
evet
peki
şimdi
şöyle yapalım
şunu tekrar
yorum satırından
çıkartalım
en son
neyi görmüş olduk?
covariance konusunu
görmüş olduk
ama şimdi
ondan da
daha önemli
bir konumuz var
hemen başlığımızı
atalım
virtual
destructor
arkadaşlar
virtual
constructor
olmaz
dedik
constructorlar için
virtual keyword'ı
kullanılmıyor
yani kullanılması
syntax hatası
olsa olsa
virtual
constructor idiom'dan
bahsetmiş olabiliriz
clone idiom'dan
ya da
create similar
idiom'undan
dedik
ama virtual
destructor var
ve virtual
destructor'ı
çok iyi
anlamamız
gerekiyor
yani çok
eğer
polimorfik
sınıfların
destructor'ını
virtual yapmazsak
başımız ciddi
derde
girebilir
tanımsız
davranış
durumu
oluşur
eğer bazı
noktalara
dikkat etmezsek
önce virtual
destructor'ın
ne olduğunu
bir
anlamaya
çalışalım
arkadaşlar
şimdi bu
polimorfik
sınıflarda
örneğin
class
base
public
virtual
white
pool
bu
bu da
türemiz
sınıflardan biri
cluster
public
base
void
pool
override
arkadaşlar
normalde
bakınız
biz dinamik
ömürlü
bir sınıf
nesnesine
örneğin
new
der
der yıldız
der ptr
oluşturduğumuzda
herkesi katli
izlesin
ve işimiz
bittiğinde
bu nesneyi
a
destroy
etmek için
yani
destructor'ın
çağrılması
b
bu nesne
için
operatör
new
çağrılıyor
bir bellek
alanı
allocate
ediyor
değil mi
operatör
new
ile allocate
edilen
bellek
bloğunun
da aynı
zamanda
geri
verilmesi
için
yani
bellek
alanını
free
etmek
için
ne
yapıyoruz
delete
ifadesini
kullanıyoruz
delete
der ptr
böylece
burada
nesnemiz
hayata
gelecek
ama
tabi
nesnemizin
hayata
gelme
sürecinde
operatör
new
yerini
ayıracak
ama
buraya
geldiğimizde
der ptr
'nin
destructor'ı
çağrılacak
arkadaşlar
der ptr
der sınıfının
destructor'ı
çağrılacak
ve
dinamik bellek
alanı
dialoget
edecek
tüpesiz
böyle yaptığım
zaman
arkadaşlar
kremis
sınıfın
destructor'ı
da
tamam sınıfın
destructor'ı
da çağrılacak
yani
onu göstermek
için bakın
base
sınıfının
destructor'ının
çağrıldığını
gösteren
bir
yazı
yazdıralım
iostream
başlık dosyasında
dahil edelim
see out
base
destructor
hatta
der sınıfının
destructor'ında
yazalım
der destructor
der
yost
ptr
new
der
ve
delete
ettiğimde
arkadaşlar
tabi ki
der sınıfının
destructor'ı
çağrılacak
der sınıfının
destructor'ının
kodu
çalıştığında
adeta
buradaki
kodla
der
içine
eklediği
kodla
der sınıf
nesnesinin
önce
arkadaşlar
hatırlayın
memberlar
taban sınıf
nesnesi
yani
hayata
gelmelerinin
ters sırasıyla
önce
memberlar
yok edilecek
sonra da
taban sınıf
nesnesi
yok edilecek
dolayısıyla
biz şu anda
base sınıfının
destructor'ına
yapılan
çağrıyı
göreceğiz
şunları da
implemente
edelim
buradaki
base'in
destructor'ı
niçin
çağrıldı
çünkü
der içindeki
base
nesnesi
için
değil mi
ama
bakın
şimdi
birçok
durumda
biz
kalıtımı
runtime
polimorfizmi
ile birlikte
kullanıyoruz
ama
runtime
polimorfizminden
faydalanırken
türemi
sınıf
nesnelerini
soban
sınıf
pointer ile
yönetiyoruz
yani
daha çok
karşımıza çıkan
manzara
şöyle oluyor ki
geçen
yazdığımız
kodda
bunun
tipik bir örneği
bakın
base
yıldız
ptr
eşittir
new
der
e şimdi
her
der nesnesi
bir
base
değil mi
dolayısıyla
der nesnesinin
adresini
base
ptr
pointer'ında
tutabilirim
böylece
virtual
dispatch'ten
faydalanabilirim
base ptr'nin
foo'su
dediğimde
der sınıfına
foo fonksiyonu
çağrılacak
izleyin
hatta
şuna da
yazdıralım
see out
base'nin
foo'su
rădere
înfosu
virtual dispatch
gerçekleşecek
virtual dispatch'in
gerçekleşme
kısmında
görelim
der nesnesi
çağrıldı. Ama şimdi ben
bunu
delete ettiğimde, delete base
PTR. Arkadaşlar
en son söyleyeceğimi en baştan
söyleyeyim. Bu tanımsız davranış.
Undefined behavior.
Şimdi bakın burada
komple term'den
base PTR'nin türü
base yıldızı olduğu için
derleyici
arkadaşlar base sınıfının
destraktırını çağıracak.
Görüyorsunuz değil mi?
Base destraktır. Arkadaşlar
yani ne demek istiyorum? Bakın bakın bakın
bu der destraktır
çağrılmadı. Sadece
base destraktır çağrıldı.
Peki normalde
ne olması gerekiyordu?
Arkadaşlar bu der nesnesi
derin destraktırının
çağrılması gerekiyordu.
Derin destraktırının kodu az önce
gösterdiğim durumda
nasılsa
bunun içindeki
base'i de
kodu çalıştıktan sonra
derin içindeki
base nesnesinin de
destraktır edilmesi
gerekiyordu.
Ama şimdi
derleyici
statik olarak
compile time'da
delete ifadesinde
standart operatör
terimini kullanmıyor.
Ama delete operatörü
değil.
Delete operatörünün
operandı
base yıldızı olduğu için
doğrudan
base sınıfının
destraktırını çağırıyor.
yani burada
problemli bir durum var
ve bu
dilin yine
kurallarına göre
standarda göre
tanımsız davranış.
Burada hem
ders sınıfının
destraktırından
çağrılması gerekiyor.
O başlı başına
bir hata.
Belki de ders sınıfının
destraktırının kodu
bir takım kaynakları
vesaire
geri verecek.
Ama yine
dinamik kömürlü
dinamik olarak
allocate edilen
bellek bloklarının
operatör delete ile
geri verilmesine de
sorun
olabilir.
O yüzden bu
tanımsız davranış olarak
kayda geçmiş.
Asla asla böyle bir
duruma müsaade
etmememiz gerekiyor.
Ama şimdi
bakın bakın
aman sınıfın
destraktırında
virtual keyword'ünü
kullanıyorum.
Yani adeta
diğer sanal
fonksiyonlar gibi
ve bu durumda
bu destraktır
işte
virtual destraktır
oluyor.
Virtual destraktır
olmasının
sonucunu
tahmin edebiliyorsunuz.
Ama bir gösterelim.
Arkadaşlar
bir
aman sınıf
pointer'ı
delete ifadesi
olduğu zaman
burada
derleyici
normalde
az önceki örnekte
base sınıfının
destraktırını
çağırmıştı.
Oysa şimdi
der sınıfının
destraktırını
çağıracak.
Olması gerektiği gibi.
Bakın.
gördüğünüz gibi
önce der
destraktırı
çağırıldı.
Onun
kodu
çalıştığında
sonunda
tıpkı
normal
der nesnelerinde
olması
gerektiği gibi
base'in
destraktırı
çağırıldı.
Şimdi bu
şu demek.
Buradan
şimdi çok
önemli
bir yere
gideceğiz.
Arkadaşlar
o zaman
iki tane
ihtimal var.
Bir
eğer siz
türemiş sınıf
nesnelerini
bu örnekte
olduğu gibi
kodların
çok büyük
çoğunluğunda
olduğu gibi
rantal
polymortizminin
kullanıldığı
türemiş sınıf
nesnelerini
avant sınıf
pointerıyla
delete
edecekseniz
yani böyle bir
ihtimal varsa
böyle bir
delete etme
senaryosu
varsa
mutlaka
avant sınıfın
destraktırı
virtual
olmalı.
Evet
tabanın
polymortik
sınıfların
arkadaşlar
polymortik
taban sınıfların
destraktırı
bakın burası
çok önemli
şimdi
A
public
virtual
bu da
Herb Satır'ın
ünlü bir
makalesinin
ne diyelim
ilkeleştirdiği
bir cümle
ya
public
virtual
olmalı
ya
protected
non
virtual
olmalı
ne demek bu
arkadaşlar
son derece
basit
eğer
siz
türemiş sınıf
nesnelerinin
taban sınıf
pointerlarıyla
işlenmesi
ve taban sınıf
pointerıyla
delete edilmesine
izin veriyorsanız
yani bu doğal bir durum
ise
bir kere
kesinlikle
destraktır
ne olmalı?
Arkadaşlar
virtual ve
public olmalı.
Dolayısıyla
bu örnekte
gördüğünüz gibi
delete
ve
SPTR
ne olmayacak?
Bir
sentaks
hatası
olmayacak ve
çalışması
gerektiği gibi
çalışacak.
ama bir ihtimal
daha var.
Siz
küçük bir ihtimal
de olsa
arkadaşlar
siz
taban sınıf
pointerıyla
türemiş sınıf
nesnesini
hiçbir zaman
delete
etmeyecekseniz
o zaman
bunu
virtual yapmak
yerine
non virtual
yapıp
bunu
protected
yapabilirsiniz.
Bu ne demek?
Bu durumda
bakınız
izleyin
taban sınıfın
destraktörü
protected
ve
base
PTR
fu
bu arada
çalıştırıyorum
bakınız
neden
sentaks
hatası
oldu?
Son derece
basit
delete
base
PTR
demek
aslında
base
PTR
yani base
sınıfının
destraktörüne
yapılan çağrı
demek.
Destraktör
da protected
olduğu için
sentaks
hatası
oluyor.
Derleyicinin
verdiği hata
mesajına
bakar mısınız?
Base
cannot
access
protected
member
declared
in class
based
yani
derleyici
protected
olan
destraktörü
yapılan
çağrının
sentaks
hatası
olduğunu
belirtiyor.
Böylece
eğer bu
istenmiyorsa
fakat
işte
gördüğümüz gibi
yanlışlıkla
yani
genel
stratejiden
farklı
olarak
türemiş
sınıf
nesnesi
havan sınıf
pointer ile
delete
edit edildiğinde
sentaks
hatası
olacak.
Ama eğer
böyle bir durum
yoksa
mesela
şöyle
olsaydı
buraya dikkat
der
yıldız
ptr
eşittir
arkadaşlar
niv
der
ve
bilit
der
ptr
şimdi
sentaks
hatası
neden
şimdi
sentaks
hatası
olmuyor?
çünkü
türemiş
sınıfın
destraktarı
fabrik
ama
türemiş
sınıfın
destraktarı
taban sınıfın
protektif bölümüne
erişebiliyor
değil mi?
Evet
arkadaşlar
şimdi o gerçekten
bu kalıtım
konusundaki en önemli
makalelerden biri
çünkü aynı
makalede
ilerleyen
derslerden
birinde
anlatacağım
ve çok da
önemli kabul edilen
non-virtual
interface
videomu da
anlatılıyor
bu
Herb Sutter'ın
aslında ilk
ilkeleştirdiği
teknik
ya da
video
non-virtual
yani
aslında şu
tek bir makale
onu bulabilirsiniz
hatta arkadaşlarım
ben bir
hemen bir link de
verebilir
a
tavan sınıfların
polimorfik sınıfların
destraktarı
ya
public virtual
protected
non-virtual
olmalı
işte bu
anlattığım konu
bir de
bununla
doğrudan
ilgili olması
da
non-virtual
idiom
tekniğinin
ya da
adı üstünde
idiomunun
anlatıldığı
makale
non-virtual
idiom
ne olduğundan
biraz bahsedelim
ama çok detaya
girmeden
arkadaşlar
non-virtual
interface
yani
bu teknik
ya da bu
idiomatik
yaklaşım
diyor ki
tavan sınıfların
sanal fonksiyonu
sanal olmasın
arkadaşlar
tavan fonksiyonların
sanal fonksiyonları
sanal olmasın
tavan sınıfların
sanal fonksiyonları
public
olmasın
yani
interfeiste
virtual function
bulunmasın
burada
interface
dediği ne
sınıfın
public
interfeisi
yani örneğin
class space
normalde bizim
şimdiye kadar
yaptığımız örneklerde
hep şöyle
değil mi
public
arkadaşlar
void
bu
virtual
void
bar
virtual
şimdi
böyle
olmak yerine
diyor ki
sen bunları
private yap
arkadaşlar
fakat
senin
public
fonksiyonların
olsun
bunlar
virtual
olmasın
fakat bu fonksiyonlar
kimi çağırsın
bu
sanal fonksiyonları
çağırsın
void
bar
implementation
şimdi
başlangıçta
biraz saçma
gibi gelse de
bunun
sağladığı
önemli avantajlar
ve diğerini
yapamadığı
önemli durumlar
var
bunu bir düşünmenizi
istiyorum
ama bu
derste
anlatmayacağım
ama en azından
non virtual
interface
ne demek
işte
özetle
bu demek
arkadaşlar
hatırlayın
şimdi virtual
dispatch
mekanizmasının
devreye
girmesinde
yollardan
biri neydi
taban
sınıfın
sanal
olmayan
bir fonksiyonuna
çağrı
yapıyorsunuz
arkadaşlar
ama taban
sınıfın
sanal
olmayan
fonksiyonu
taban
sınıfın
sanal
fonksiyonuna
çağrı
yapıyor
yani şimdi
onu bir
önce hatırlamanız
gerekiyor
class
özür dilerim
void
diyelim ki
punk
punkta
polimorfik
işleme
yapılacak
base
yıldız
ptr
burada
base
ptr
ok
tuku
çağrılıyor
şimdi
soru
siz
punk fonksiyonuna
bunu geçen
hafta
görmüştük
siz
punk fonksiyonuna
base
sınıfından
kalıtım
yoluyla
elde edilen
bir sınıf
türünden
nesnenin adresini
gönderirseniz
burada
virtual dispatch
mekanizması
devreye girer
değil mi
evet
doğrudan
bu fonksiyonları
sanal yapmak
yerine
implementasyon
kısmını
virtual yapıp
non-virtual
member function'ın
virtual
function'ı
çağırmasına
sıra alıyoruz
buna
non-virtual
interface
gidiyor mu
deniyor
evet
neden buna
değindim
aynı makalede
aslında
o makalende
linkini
ben dersten sonra
bulup
telegram grubunda
paylaşırım
okumak
çok şey kazandırır
ama
bunu da
ilerleyen haftalarda
anlatacağım
şimdi oraya çok fazla
girip konuyu
başka başka yerlere
götürmek istemiyorum
evet
böylece
virtual destructor
arkadaşlar
özetle
bugün hiçbir şey
aklınızda kalmadıysa
sanal fonksiyon
taban sınıfların
polimorfik
destructorının
virtual olması
gerekiyor
eğer virtual
ise public
virtual olmasını
istemiyorsanız da
protected
non-virtual
yapmalısınız
deniyor
önce bunu da
bir
ne yapmış oldu
konuşmuş olduk
şimdi önümüzde
hangi konular var
arkadaşlar
önemli bir
bağlamsal anahtar
sözcük daha
şöyle bir not alalım
neleri göreceğiz
final
keyword'ü
contextual keyword'ü
bunu göreceğiz
ondan sonra
private
kalıtı mı
inheritance
protected
ve
multiple
inheritance
ama ondan önce
yine
pratikte önemli bir
ihtiyaçtan bahsedelim
arkadaşlar
soru
hangi fonksiyonlar
virtual keyword'ü
ile nitelenebilir
bir kere
sınıfın
constructor'ı
virtual olamaz
dedik
yani
parametreli
constructor
default
copy
constructor
null
bunların
virtual olma
şansı yok
dilin sentaksına
göre
destructor
virtual olabilir
sınıfın
statiküya
fonksiyonları
için
yine
virtual
function
kavramı
yok
yani onlar
virtual olamaz
global
fonksiyonları
yine ne
olamaz
arkadaşlar
virtual
olamaz
fakat
bazen
bizim
global
fonksiyonları
virtual
yapacak
bir
yola
başvurmamız
gerekiyor
mesela çok
tipik bir örnek
hem üretimde
karşımıza çıkabilecek
hem de
mülakatlarda da
çok sık sorulan
bir örnek
şimdi şu bizim
kar yerarşisine
tekrar bir
gidelim
orayı bir
hatırlatayım
işte
kar sınıfı
var
arkadaşlar
gördüğünüz gibi
bu arada
kar sınıfının
destruktor'ının
arkadaşlar
virtual olduğunu
görürsünüz
mesela bakın
bu örnek
aslında az önce
anlattığım konuyu da
çok güzel gösteriyor
demin şöyle bir
kod yazmıştık ya
kar game
isimli fonksiyonumuz
vardı
bunu yazmayacağım
tekrar
kar game
kar yıldız
p
ve ben şöyle bir
kod yazdım
orayı hatırlıyorsunuz
kar yıldız p
eşittir
arkadaşlar
create random car
e şimdi soru
fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş değeri
kar yıldız
onu
kar pointer'ında
tuttum
ama şimdi bu
kar pointer'ı
BMW'yi de
Mercedes de
gösteriyor olabilir
polimorfik işleme
için
kar game
fonksiyonuna
kar pointer'ını
argüman olarak
gönderdim
ama
döngünün bir
sonraki
durumu
geçmeden
nesneyi
delete ettim
işte bakın
eğer bu
senaryoda
kar sınıfının
destruktor'ı
virtual olmasaydı
bu durumda
tanımsız
davranış
olacaktı
öyle değil mi
az önce söylediğim
durumun
ta kendisi
onu da tekrar
bir
değinmiş olduk
ama şimdi
sorumuza gelelim
arkadaşlar
peki
kar game
yine kalsın
hatta
kalkmasın
şurada
doğrudan
çağıralım
p
ok
start
p ok
ram
iki tanesi
yeter
döngünün
her turunda
delete edeceğim
bu da okey
ama şöyle bir şey
istiyorum
buraya dikkat
c out
so c out
yıldız p
bu kod level olacak
buraya dikkat
bu
polimorfik olarak
çalışacak
önce talebin
ne olduğunu
anladınız mı
bakın
polimorfik olarak
çalışacak
dergen
şunu söylüyorum
şunu demek
istiyorum
mesela
buraya
burada
sekizinci satırda
tabi
runtime'den bahsediyorum
oluşturulan
nesne
volvoysa
burada
arkadaşlar
ne olsun
mesela şöyle bir
yazı çıksın
oyun değil mi
i'm a volvo
reno'ysa
i'm a reno
fiyatsa
anında fiyat yazısı
çıksın
ama şimdi şöyle bir
problem var
buradaki
inserter
global bir
fonksiyon
olabilir
çünkü bu bir
custom type
yani düşünün
aslında benim
yaptığım
operatör
lab shift'i
stut c out
mesnesini
ve
yıldız p
argüman olarak
gönderiyorum
fonksiyon çağrısı
bu
ama bu fonksiyon
sanal olamaz ki
bu fonksiyon
virtual olamaz
çünkü global bir
fonksiyon
c++ dilinde global
bir fonksiyonun
virtual olma
ihtimali yok
o zaman peki
bunu nasıl yapacağım
bu yapılabilir
bir şey mi
öyle ya da böyle
bir düşünmenizi
istiyorum
bu da yine
tipik
mülakatlarda
sorulan
kalıtımla ilgili
sorulardan
yani
adeta
global fonksiyonu
virtualize
etmem gerekiyor
arkadaşlar
aslında düşünürseniz
zor değil
neden zor değil
bakın şimdi
önce buradaki fonksiyon
bir kere
taban sınıfın
fonksiyonu
olmalı
değil mi
onda problem yok
gidelim
taban sınıfa
arkadaşlar
operatör
lab shift
brand
get o brand
yapıyorum
geri dönüş
değeri
stud
o stream
ref
operatör
lab shift
ancak böyle bir fonksiyon
olabilir ama
bu da sanal
olamaz
stud
o stream
ref
os
bu da
par
const
ref
c
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
e çağırılan fonksiyon
bu fonksiyon
olacak
bu sanal
olamaz ki
bu global
bir fonksiyon
free
function
ama şunu
yapabilirim
bakın bakın
şunu yapabilirim
bu fonksiyonu
implemente
ederken
arkadaşlar
bu sefer
tam tersi
karın
örneğin print
isimli bir fonksiyonu
olsa
ben karın
print fonksiyonuna
tam tersi
os'e
argüman
olarak geçsem
şunu yorum
satırına
alayım
takip
edebiliyor
muyuz
return
os
ve
buradaki
print fonksiyonu
virtual
function
olsa
o zaman
burada
virtual
dispatch
devreye girer
değil mi
olsan
anladık mı
alian
kaan
can
mehmet
be
oğsan
rasul
ve
evet
bunu yapabilirim
hadi yapalım
yapmayı deneyelim
şimdi
bir iki şeye
dikkat etmemiz
gerekecek
bir kere
buraya bir sanal fonksiyon
koyuyorum
virtual
arkadaşlar
diyelim ki
ismi
print olsun
zaten print
ismini aşağıda
kullandım
geri dönüş
değeri
stud
o stream
ref olsun
parametresi
stud
o stream
ref olsun
ve bu fonksiyon
pure
virtual
olsun
buraya kadar
bir şey yok
değil mi
tamam
ve şimdi
ben
c'nin
print fonksiyonunu
çağırdığımda
yukarıdaki
sanal fonksiyonu
çağırmış olacağım
öyle değil mi
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
ama tabi
bunun
konstya fonksiyonu
olmasına
gerekiyor
nesne konstya
tamam
hatta
şöyle yazabilirim
bu çok şık olacak
buraya kadar
anlamadığımız bir şey
var mı
bir daha bakalım
14. satırda
bildirimi yapılan
bir pure
virtual
function
haval sınıfın
print isimli
fonksiyonu
constya fonksiyon
bu
sonuçta
non static
member
function
sanal
olabilir
const ya da
const olmayan
bir
üye fonksiyon
söz konusu
olabilir
virtual
dolayısıyla
bunu
türemiz sınıflar
override
edebilir
şimdi
override
ederim bunu
dikkatli bir şekilde
bakı şu anda
syntax hatası
bildirimizin
nedeni
biz bu
sanal fonksiyonu
pure virtual
yaptık
mercedes
sınıfı
override
etmedi
etmediği için
mercedes
sınıfı da
şimdi
abstract
class oldu
mercedes
sınıfı da
abstract
class olduğu için
derleyicimiz burası için
28. satırdaki kod için
doğal olarak
syntax hatası
veriyor ama
şimdi ben
print fonksiyonunu
override ettiğim anda
o syntax hatası
ortadan kalkacak
evet
şimdi
şuradan
kopyalayalım
yanlış
olmasın
evet
const
override
nesnemize isim verelim
ve
return
os
i
i am
mercedes
şimdi bunu alayım
biraz
şöyle diyorlar ya
ingilizce'de
bear with me
biraz sabredim
benim için sabır gösterin
anlamında
evet
bu
reno
fiyat
efendim bu
var
volvo
xc90
adi
i am
an
adi
opel
port
tamam
şimdi
bir syntax hatası
olmadığını
göstermek için
emirhan çelik
ben print
func override edilmeden
clone neden
syntax hatası oldu
kaçırdım
açıklayayım emirhan
çok basit
şimdi
hatırlıyor musunuz
geçen derste
konuşmuştuk
abstract class
soyut sınıf
concrete class
a
bir sınıfın
bir pure virtual
function'ı varsa
o sınıf
soyut sınıftır
abstract
class'tır
emirhan
abstract class
türünden
nesne
oluşturamazsınız
bunu hatırladık mı
ama
bir abstract
class'tan
kalıtım yoluyla
bir sınıf
elde ettiğimde
kalıtım yoluyla
elde edilen
sınıfın
abstract olmaması
için
concrete
olması için
yani kalıtım
yoluyla elde edilen
sınıf
türünden
nesne
oluşturabilmem
için
tavan sınıfın
base class'ın
bütün
sanal fonksiyonlarını
override
etmem gerekir
şimdi o zaman
açıklamayı
izlemeye çalışın
ben
bu
print fonksiyonunu
eklemeden önce
sınıfın
tüm
pure virtual
function'ları
bunlardı
emirhan
evet
dolayısıyla
bunlar zaten
override
edildiği için
bütün
sınıflar
neydi
arkadaşlar
efendim
concrete
olmuştu
ama şimdi
ben
taban sınıfın
interfazine
bu pure
virtual
function'ı
eklediğim
için
artık
kar sınıfından
kalıtım yoluyla
elde edilen
örneğin
mercedes
sınıfı
bunu override
etmediği zaman
artık
abstract
class oluyor
class türünden
nesne oluşturamam
ama burada bir
mercedes nesnesi
oluşturma ifadesi var
dolayısıyla şu anda
derlediğimde
derleyici
abstract sınıf
türünden
nesne oluşturamazsın
hatasını verecek
hatırladınız
değil mi
evet
peki
şimdi buraya
gelelim
Alihan Bozkır
hocam sadece
pure'lar için
geçerli
evet
sadece pure'lar için
geçerli
zaten eğer
pure virtual
function değilse
Alihan
virtual function ise
zaten onun varlık
nedeni o
virtual function'lar
ne diyordu
hey türemiş sınıflar
ben size bir
interface veriyorum
ama bir de
default
implementasyon
veriyorum
sizin
interface'iniz var
sizde de
bu metot
var
ama
eğer
bu metot için
benim kodumun
çalışmasını
istiyorsanız
ben size
default bir kod
veriyorum
hiçbir şey
yapmayacaksınız
ama
kendi
kodunuzu
oluşturmak
istiyorsanız
yani bu
metot çağrıldığında
kendi kodunuzun
çalışmasını
istiyorsanız
kendi kodunuzu
vereceksiniz
işte o kendi
kodunuzu vereceksiniz
anlamında
yaptığımız
o fonksiyonu
override
etmek
evet
peki
şimdi
burada
gerçekten çalışıyor
mu
bakalım
void
get car
derleniyor
mu
görüyorsunuz
sanal fonksiyon
olmamasına rağmen
global fonksiyon
derlendi
ferman time'a
bakıyoruz
i'm an audi
i'm a fiat
i'm an opel
i'm an audi
fiat
fiat ve opel dışında
bir şey yok mu
volvo x c 90
evet
peki
süper
o zaman
ara verme
vaktimiz de geldi
saat 21.10
diyelim
21.30
da devam edelim
arkadaşlar
ara veriyoruz
evet
kaldığımız yerden
devam ediyoruz
şimdi
final
contextual
keyword'üne
bir bakalım
yine modern
c++'la
dileklenen
anahtar
sözcüklerden
biri
arkadaşlar
final
contextual
keyword'ü
iki farklı
biçimde
kullanılıyor
bir
bir sınıfın
final class
yapılması
iki
bir
polimorfik
sınıfın
kanal fonksiyonunun
final yapılması
buradaki kullanıma
popüler olarak
final class
buradaki fonksiyonu
nitelerden de
final override
terimini
kullanıyoruz
her ikisinde de
aynı contextual
keyword'ü
kullanılıyor
geçen dersimizde
söylemiştik
bir kez daha
tekrar etmekte
fayda var
gerek
final
override
bunlar
contextual
keyword
yani
belirli bir bağlamda
kullanıldıkları zaman
anahtar
sözcük
keyword etkisi
yapıyor
ama o bağlamın
dışında
arkadaşlar
anahtar
sözcük
olarak
el
alınmıyor
yani bir identifier
olarak bir isim
olarak
kullanılabiliyor
bazen
oluşturduğumuz
sınıfları
A
ya doğrudan
kalıtıma
kapatmak istiyoruz
yani o sınıftan
kalıtım yapılması
stratejik olarak
bir
istenmeyen
durumu
oluşturuyor
bazen de
kalıtımda
belirli bir
seviyeden sonra
tekrar kalıtım
yapılmasını
istemiyoruz
her ikisinde de
daha önce
arkadaşlar
bunu belirtmek için
yorum satırı
kullanılıyordu
ve yine yorum
satırıyla yazılan
sözcük
final'dı
fakat
C++'da
önce bazı
başka dillerde
zaten bu
anahtar sözcük
olarak benzer
durumu
garanti altına
almak için
anahtar sözcükler
mevcut idi
işte modern
C++'da
C'ye de
C++'a da
final
contextual
keyword'u
geldi
hemen gösterelim
bir sınıfımız var
arkadaşlar
class
net
final
ister sınıfı
doğrudan
final olarak
belirtebilirsiniz
bu durumda
derleyiciye ve okuyucuya
neyi belirtmiş
oluyorsunuz
bu sınıftan
kalıtım
yapılmayacak
kalıtım yapılması
istenmiyor
şimdi bu sınıfı
taban sınıfı
olarak kullanıp
net sınıfından
kalıtımla bir sınıf
elde etme
gelişimine
olunma
sentaks hatası
oluşturacak
isterseniz deneyelim
bakın buraya kadar
bir
sentaks hatası
yok
ama
class
er
public
net
derleyici
durumu
sentaks hatası
olarak
değerlendirdi
ve sentaks hatası
mesajına
bakarsanız
ne diyor
arkadaşlar
erk
cannot inherit
from net
as it's
been declared
as
final
yani
final olarak
bildirildiği için
final sınıftan
kalıtım
yapamazsın
diyor
anlaşıldı mı
ama bu
illa
arkadaşlar
bu seviyede
olmak zorunda
değil
mesela şöyle de
olabilir
class net
class
erk
şimdi ben
erkten de
kalıtım yoluyla
bir sınıf
oluşturabilirim
değil mi
o zaman şöyle
yazarsam
örneğin
class
efendim
bar
public
erk
bu
bu da herhangi bir şekilde
bir
sentaks hatası
değil
ama
class
erk'in
kendisini
final olarak
belirseydim
şimdi artık
match
final değil
ama erk
final
dolayısıyla
erk
kalıtım
hiyerarşisindeki
son yaprak
olacak
artık bundan sonra
bundan kalıtım yapılması
istenmiyor
demek
bu final
class
yani
bir sınıfı
özetle
final olarak
nitelersem
artık o sınıfı
kalıtıma
tapatmış
oluyorum
kalıtımda
taban sınıfı
olarak
kullanılamaz
demiş oluyorum
ve
ister doğrudan
bir sınıfı
bu kullanım
son 4-5 senede
bu da yaygınlaştı
eskiden burada
kullanmayı
tercih etmiyorduk
ama şimdi
bu kalıtımla
bu sınıfın
alakası yok
arkadaşlar
orada şunu da söyleyelim
bakın
şimdi
konuyla yeni tanışanlar
şöyle bir algı
elde edebiliyorlar
her sınıfı
ben kalıtımda
kullanabilirim
hayır bir kere
böyle bir şey yok
yani tipik olarak
atipik senaryolar
mutlaka olacaktır
ama tipik olarak
bir sınıf
kalıtımda
kullanılmak üzere
tasarlanıyor
genel olarak
yani herhangi bir sınıfı
kalıtımda
taban sınıfı
olarak kullanmak
doğru bir yaklaşım
olmayabilir
o yüzden
bir sınıftan
kalıtım yaparken
şuna dikkat etmek
gerekiyor
yani gerçekten
o sınıf
kalıtım amaçlı mı
kalıtımla kendisinden
sınıf oluşturabilsin diye mi
oluşturulmuş
işte eskiden bu
final keyword olmadığında
bu çok belirgin
değildi
dokümentasyon dışında
ama şimdi ben
örneğin bu sınıfın
kalıtımla
hiçbir alakası yok
demek istiyorsam
ben de burada
final keyword'ı
kullanıyorum
ama diğer kullanımı
daha özel
yani artık
kalıtımda bu
son yaprak
son child
bunun kendisi
multi-level
inheritance'da
taban sınıfı
olarak
kullanılmayacak
anlamında
fakat bir de
arkadaşlar
final override var
final override ise
ben
türemiz sınıfım
taban sınıfın
sanal fonksiyonunu
override ediyorum
ama benden kalıtım yoluyla
elde edilen sınıflar
artık benim override'ımı
kullanacaklar
onlara tekrar override etme
hakkını
vermiyorum
dedi
mesela
class base
arkadaşlar
public
virtual
void
who
cluster
efendim
public
base
ve
diyelim ki
public
void
who
override
şimdi ders sınıfı
base sınıfının
full fonksiyonunu
override etti
gördüğünüz gibi
fakat
derden de yeni bir sınıf
oluşturuyorum
yani multi-level
inertness uyguluyorum
class
who
public
der
bu da override
edebilir
public
void
who
override
burada bir
santaksi hatası yok
fakat
arkadaşlar
bu
final
override
olsaydı
artık
derden
bakın
sınıfın kendisi
final değil
ama
override
final
yani derden yeni bir sınıf elde edildi
buraya kadar bir hata yok
ama
bu fonksiyonu
derden
kalıtım yoluyla elde edilen
full sınıfının
override etmesi
sentaks hatası
okuyalım
der
full
özellikle
function declared
as
final
cannot be
overridden
by
full
anlaşıldı mı
sınıfı ismiyle
fonksiyon
isminde aynı
olması
siz başka bir yere
yönlendirmesin diye
ismini
erk yapayım
onunla doğrudan
bir ilgisi yok
evet
bu arada
bu anahtar sözcükler
birden fazla olduğu zaman
arkadaşlar
bazı durumlarda
yerleri
fark etmiyor
bazı anahtar sözcüklerin
yeri fark ediyor
örneğin
exception
linkte
bununla
karşılaşacağız
bakın
final
override da desem
override final da desem
anlamsal açıdan
bir farkı yok
ama mesela bu
const
fiyafonksiyon
olsaydı
şöyle diyemezdim
override final
const
çünkü const
imzanın parçası
yani const
örneğin
buraya koyamam
şuraya koymak zorunda
evet
o zaman
şimdi
nereye gelelim
private ve protected
inheritance'a gelelim
arkadaşlar bu konu
biraz zorlayıcı
öncelikle
konunun başında
şöyle demiştik
c sharp java
ve birçok
programlama dilinde
kalıtım
dendiği zaman
inheritance
ise
relationship
anlaşılıyor
fakat
c++'da
bu cümleyi
birkaç kez
tekrar ettim
inheritance
is a relationship'i
aşkın bir özellik
onun üstünde
kalıtımın
sadece
is a relationship
olarak
kullanılabilecek
bir kısmı var
işte o bizdeki
public inheritance
fakat
bunun dışında
protected
private ve protected
inheritance
dediğimiz
iki kalıtım
biçimi
daha var
ve gerek
private inheritance
gerek protected
inheritance
is a relationship
den ziyade
ki onunla da
bir ilgisi
var yine
ama daha çok
has a relationship
ile ilgili
o zaman
hemen konuya
giriş yapalım
önce
daha önce
öğrendiklerimizin
bir kısmını
hatırlayalım
dedik ki
bizde
üç ayrı
kalıtım
biçimi var
neydi bunlar
arkadaşlar
public inheritance
private inheritance
ve protected inheritance
eğer
class keyword
ını kullanıyorsanız
kalıtımda
elde ettiğiniz
sınıf için
class
der
inheritance
biçimini anlatan
specifier'i yazmazsanız
default'u
private inheritance
yani ilginç
en çok kullanılan
public inheritance
olmasına rağmen
sınıf oluşturduğunuzda
public private
ya da protected
anahtar sözcüklerinden
birini yazmazsanız
private
inheritance
olduğunu
hatırlayın
yani
ister
der bir sınıfını
böyle oluşturun
ister
der iki sınıfını
şurada
private
keyword
ile oluşturun
her ikisi de
arkadaşlar
private inheritance
ve farklı özelliklere
sahip
oysa
public anahtar sözcüğünü
kullanırsak
public inheritance
oluyor
ya da
struct anahtar
sözcüğünü
kullanıp
arkadaşlar
public private
ya da protected
belirtecini
specifier'ını
koymazsak
yine
public
inheritance
oluyor
dolayısıyla
aslında
burada
dilin kuralları
şöyleydi
değil mi
public
anahtar sözcüğünü
kullanırsak
public inheritance
private
anahtar sözcüğünü
kullanırsak
private
inheritance
ve
değerli arkadaşlar
hiç
anahtar sözcüğü
kullanmazsak
ama önce
protected
yazalım
bu da protected
inheritance
kadar basit
böyle basit
ama
class
anahtar sözcüğünü
kullanıp
burada
kullanmazsak
public
private
ya da protected
inheritance
sözcüğünü
ama
start
sözcüğünü
kullanırsak
böylece özetlemiş
olduk
yine
public
inheritance
değişen
ne
buraya çok
izleyin
normalde
public
inheritance
taban sınıfın
public bölümünü
kendi public bölümüne
katıyorum
yani taban sınıfın
public interfejsi
türemiz sınıfında
public interfejsinin
bir parçası
taban sınıfın
private
interfejsi
türemiz sınıf
tarafından
ulaşılamıyor
yani
private
interfej
öğeler
hem
client'lara
kapalı
hem de
türemiz sınıflara
kapalı
ama protected
bölümün özelliği
neydi
client'lara
kapalı
ama türemiz sınıfları
açık
public
interfejsi
public inheritance
böyle özetleyebiliriz
yani public
inheritance
sınıfın
taban sınıfın
public bölümünün
türemiz sınıfın
public bölümüne
eklemlendiği
taban sınıfın
protected bölümünün
türemiz sınıfın
protected bölümüne
eklemlendiği
arkadaşlar
inheritance
fakat
private inheritance
böyle değil
da
taban sınıfın
public bölümü
türemiz sınıfın
private bölümüne
ekleniyor
taban sınıfın
public
öğeleri
memberları
türemiz sınıfın
private bölümüne
ekleniyor
bu ne demek
mesela bakınız
göstermek için
3 kısmı da
bakalım
public
protected
arkadaşlar ve
private
who
public
geri dönüş değeri
olmasın
who
are
protected
ve
void
bom
private
şimdi
private kalıtımıyla
bir sınıf
oluşturuyorum
class
der
base
private
anahtar sözcüğünü
kullanmakla
kullanmamak
arasında
bir fark yok
gezavır
kullanmış
olalım
şimdi artık
taban sınıfın
public bölümü
benim private bölümüne
kendi
bu ne demek
soru
eğer bu public
kalıtım olsaydı
derma
dash
my dash
nokta
bu public
bu
syntax hatası
olmayacaktı
oysa şimdi
syntax hatası
çünkü benim
private bölümüne
kendi
lütfen
anladığınızdan emin olun
bu geçersiz
invalid
yani benim
client'larım açısından
bu benim
private
formüsüm
e doğal olarak
my dash
nokta
arkadaşlar
bar protected
bu da
syntax hatası
bu da benim
protected bölümüne
eklendi
bu da
geçersiz
zaten
taban sınıfın
private bölümüne
kimse
erişemiyor
bunu yazmaya bile
gerek
ama yine de
yazalım
my dash
efendim
bond private
üçü de
yerir
ama şimdi
türemiz sınıfın
üye fonksiyonu
açısından
bakarsak
diyelim ki
türemiz sınıfın
derfang
kesiminde
bir fonksiyonu
var
buraya
dikkat işte
soru
derfang
fonksiyonu
avans sınıfın
public fonksiyonu
foo public'i çağırabilir mi
cevap
evet
çünkü
benim private bölümümdeymiş gibi
ele alınacak
yani ben hala buna
erişebiliyorum
isterseniz bakın
foo
public
derliyorum
herhangi bir hata yok
arkadaşlar
peki
sadece şu nesne
kullanılmadığı için
derleyici uyarı
mesajı var
devam
peki
bar protected
fonksiyonunu
çağırabilir miyim
evet
çünkü bu da benim
yine
protected bölümümde
efendim
bond private
fonksiyonunu
çağırabilir miyim
bu
hayır
bir kere bütün kalıtım
biçimlerinde
taban sınıfın
private bölümü
kapalı
ya public kalıtımında da
türemiş sınıfa kapalı
private kalıtımında da
kapalı
protected kalıtımında da
bu her zaman
arkadaşlar
fantax hatası
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
peki
şimdi devam
neden böyle bir şey yapalım
neden
private kalıtımını
gerçekleştirelim
yalnız
genelde
private kalıtımında
göz ardı edilen
önemli bir özellik var
onu
söylemeliyim
arkadaşlar
bir
private kalıtımında
artık
is a relationship
client'lar açısından yok
yani
normalde
public kalıtım olsaydı
her der bir
base
değil mi
bakın
şimdi onu uygulamaya kalkalım
arkadaşlar
tabi tabi
emiram
friend bildirimi
her zaman
geçerli
yani erişim hakkı için
bakın bakın şimdi
der
myder
base
yıldız
base ptr
public kalıtı mı
olsaydı
bu geçerli
olacaktı
değil mi
address myder
upcasting
geçerli
olacaktı
değil mi
oysa
geçerli
değil
takip edebiliyor muyuz
bu
geçersiz
yani
in
ben
bir
korum
ister
pointer semantili
olsun
ister
referans
semantili
olsun
base
ref
eşittir
arkadaşlar
adres
adres diyorum
myder
her ikisi de
syntax
atası
burayı anlamamız çok önemli
yani private kalıtımında
blind kodlar için
is a relation
söz konusu
olmadığından
artık her der
bir base
olmadığı için
upcasting
yani türemiz
sınıftan
taban sınıfa
doğru dönüşüm
yok
dolayısıyla böyle bir kod
syntax hatası oluşturuyor
yalnız
genelde bilinmeyen
dikkate alınmayan
bir yer var ki
türemiz sınıfın
üye fonksiyonları içinde
durum böyle değil
yani orada halen
is a relationship
var
yani
arkadaşlar
bu demektir ki
örneğin
az önceki kodu
aslında silmeseymişim
tamam
bakın bakın
az önceki kodları
alıyorum
kesiyorum
at
şuraya koyuyorum
arkadaşlar
demin syntax hatası
vardı
şimdi syntax hatası yok
aradaki farkı
anladık değil mi
upcasting
hiç yok
değil
is a relationship
hiç yok
değil
is a relationship
kimlere var
türemiz sınıfın
üye fonksiyonlarına
ve türemiz sınıfın
friendlerine
bakın şimdi
void
gf
gf içine de
bu kodu
koyuyorum
sentaks hatası
ama
türemiz sınıf
gf fonksiyonla
friendlik versin
friend
void
arkadaşlar
gf
gördüğünüz gibi
sentaks hatası
ortadan kalktı
bir kez daha
tekrar edelim mi
is a relationship
sınırlı olarak var
client'lara yok
ama türemiz sınıfın
üye fonksiyonları içinde
halen
her der
bir
base'dir
ilişkisi
yani
is a relationship
korunuyor
ya da türemiz sınıfın
friendlik verdiği
fonksiyonlarda
kodlarda
sınıflarda
bu
korunuyor
burayı
anladığınızı
umuyorum
evet
arkadaşlar
şimdi
gelelim
private kalıtımının
kullanıldığı
senaryolara
niye private kalıtımı
kullanayım
şimdi herkes çok
dikkatli izliyor
bundan sonrası
biraz daha karmaşık
şunu
notlar
dosyamıza
koyalım
şimdilik
arkadaşlar
normalde
private kalıtımı
containment'a
bir alternatif
containment derken
kastettiğim
member
olarak
kompozisyon
yapmak
yani pointer yoluyla
değil de member yoluyla
kompozisyon yapmak
bakın şimdi
class
member
herkes dikkatli izliyor
ya da şöyle diyelim
class member
demeyelim de
class
x
nec
soru
nec'in
x türünden
elemanı
olabilir
değil mi
kesinlikle
işte buradaki
durum
arkadaşlar
şimdi
bu
kompozisyon
containment yoluyla
burada
neler
yapabileceğimizi
yapamayacağımızı
bir konuşalım
çünkü
private kalıtı mı
çok büyük
çoğunlukla
işte buna
bir alternatif
şimdi
sorulara cevap
vermeye çalışın
her nec
nesnesinin içinde
bir x var mı
cevap
kesinlikle
peki
şimdi soruya cevap
vermeye çalışın
class
erg
private
arkadaşlar
x
her nec
nesnesinin içinde
bir x
var mı
evet
her erg
nesnesinin içinde
bir x
var mı
cevap
yine
evet
arkadaşlar
türemiz
sınıfta
kalıtımda
kalıtım
biçimi
private
de olsa
protected
public
de olsa
türemiz
sınıf
nesnesinin
içinde
bir taban
sınıf
nesnesi
var
değil mi
şimdi
o açıdan
bir fark yok
devam edelim
peki
soru
public
void
who
x
soru
containment
da
member
ın
public
interfejsi
onların
public
interfejsinin
bir parçası
mı
yani bu
ne demek
x'in
client'ları
özür dilerim
nec'in
client'ları
nec nesnesiyle
doğrudan
xful
fonksiyonunu
çağırabilir mi
meriş bey
alem bey
cevap
hayır
ne demek
istediğimi
anlıyorsunuz
değil mi
yani örneğin
nec türünden
my nec
erk türünden
my erk
şimdi
her ikisi
içinde
soruyorum
soru 1
my nec
nokta
xful
geçerli mi
cevap
hayır
çünkü
bu
memberın
bir
fonksiyonu
peki
my
erk
nokta
xful
geçerli mi
cevap
yine
hayır
neden
çünkü
taban sınıfın
public bölümü
benim
private bölümüm
öyle değil mi
dolayısıyla
erk sınıfının
public
interfejsinde
xful
yok
bu açıdan da bir fark
buraya kadar anlaşıldı mı
yok
peki ikinci soru
soru
ben
containment'ta
elemanımın
xful
fonksiyonunu
kendi
interfejsime
katabilir miyim
doğrudan
kural olarak
katılmıyor
ama istesem
katabilir miyim
cevap
evet
peki
nasıl
son derece
basit
bir
forwarding
function
yazın
buradaki
forwarding
terimi
perfect
forwarding
anlamında
değil
yani
net sınıfına
da bir
xful
fonksiyonu
koyarım
ama bu
xful
fonksiyonu
member'ın
xful
sunu
çağırır
öyle değil mi
herhangi bir
şekilde bir
santart
hatası
olur mu
hayır
hatta buraya
kadar
derleyelim
arkadaşlar
bir yerde
bir
noktalı
virgül
eksik
evet
tamam
peki
o
rasul
benim
sorumudan
sormadan
sorumun
cevabını
verdi
bravo
burada
yapabilir miyim
bunu
hem
forwarding
function
ile
yapabilirim
fakat
daha kolay
ona gerek
yok
bravo
değerli arkadaşlar
sınıf
içindeki
using
bildirimi
ile bunu
yapabilirim
using
x'in
arkadaşlar
x
fu
su
o zaman
kendi
interfaysime
arkadaşlar
katmış oldum
değil mi
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
evet
artık
her ikisinde
de
isterseniz
deneyelim
my
niche
devam
ediyorum
evet
bu herhalde
en kolayı
arkadaşlar
niche
sınıfında
sınıfının
herhangi bir
üye
fonksiyonu
void
örneğin
bar
elemanın
üye
fonksiyonuna
çağrı
yapabilir mi
tabii ki
tek yapması
gereken
member'ın
fonksiyonunu
çağırmak
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
ama
burada da
zaten
arkadaşlar
void
bar
kendi
private
fonksiyonun
gibi
ele alınacağına
göre
x
boyu
böyle
çağırabilir
şimdi
buradan
şu sonuç
çıkıyor
şu ana
kadar
konuştuğumuz
özellikler
açısından
private
kalıtımı
yapmakla
member
olarak
almak
arasında
bir fark
yok
yani
member olarak
aldığımda
neler yapabiliyorsam
private
kalıtımında da
onları yapabiliyorum
ya da
neleri
yapamıyorsam
private
kalıtımında da
onları yapamıyorum
ama
şimdi
geldik
farklılıklarına
arkadaşlar
x sınıfının
bir sanal
fonksiyonu
olsaydı
virtual
void
efendim
ve
bar
ya da ne
olsa
ve
boom
eleman
olarak
aldığımda
elemanımın
sanal fonksiyonunu
override
edebilir miyim
cevap
hayır
böyle bir
santaks
özelliği yok
bunu dolaylı
bir takım
dolan başlı
yöndenme
yapabilirim
ama
doğrudan
bunu override
etmek diye
bir şey yok
değil mi
yani şöyle
yazabilir miyim
void
ve
boom
arkadaşlar
override
tabii ki
bu
santaks
hatası
böyle bir şey yok
ama şimdi
private
kalıtımını
düşünün
private
kalıtımında
bu yine
kalıtım
runtime
polymorfizmi
yine çalışacak
taban sınıfının
sanal fonksiyonunu
override
etmemde
hiçbir engel
yok
pure
virtual
olsaydı
da olurdu
bakın
neydi
ismi
bir daha
bakalım
x'in
v-boom
void
arkadaşlar
ve
override
o zaman
birinci parkı
buraya bir yazalım
private kalıtımında
private kalıtımını
kompozisyon'a
bir alternatif olarak
kullanabiliriz
ancak
containment'dan
farklı olarak
şöyle kısaca not alalım
taban sınıfın
sanal fonksiyonlarını
override
edebiliriz
birinci önemli
fark bu
yani
elemanın
sanal fonksiyonunu
override
edemezsiniz
ama yine onu
eleman gibi
kullanacağım
ama sanal fonksiyonunu
override etmek istiyorum
o zaman
private kalıtım
ben
ikinci park
arkadaşlar
eleman
olarak
aldığım zaman
tekrar buraya
geri dönelim
şöyle diyebilir miyim
her nec bir
x'dir
yani
örneğin
nec
my nec
efendim
x
yıldız
x p
d
e
eşittir
adres
my nec
saçma
olmaz
ama şimdi
bakın
diğerinde
yine olmaz
ama en azından
türemiz sınıfın
franklerinde
ve türemiz sınıfın
üye fonksiyonlarında
upcasting yapabilirim
onda bir engel yok
yani orada halen
örneğin
türemiz sınıfın
bar fonksiyonu içinde
arkadaşlar
nec
my nec
x
yıldız
ptr
eşittir
adres
my nec
uzatmaya gerek yok
bunun
yanlış yazdım
e
nec
er
nec yazmışım
özür dilerim
er
ben de diyorum
niye böyle
my er
x
yıldız
ptr
adres
my er
burada
frankler içinde
ve üye fonksiyonlar içinde
is a relationship
halen korunuyor
yani eğer
böyle bir ihtiyacım varsa
yine
kalıtım
kompozisyon yerine
kontainment
yoluyla
kompozisyon yerine
private
inheritance'ı
tercih edebilirim
o zaman iki tane
önemli senaryo var
bir
sanal fonksiyonları
override etmek
bir senaryo daha
gelecek şimdi
iki
arkadaşlar
türemiş
sanal fonksiyonları
override etmek
dedik
onu
kompozisyon da
yapamıyorum
frankler içinde
ve memberlar içinde
upcasting'den
faydalanmak
ama üçüncü bir nokta
daha var
buna herhalde
artık diğerini
peki o da kalsın
arkadaşlar
x sınıfının
protected bölümü
de olabilirdi
değil mi
protected
peki şimdi
x'in
protected bölümünde
bir tane
protected
member olsaydı
void
x
ne diyelim
pro
buraya dikkat
ne için
üye fonksiyonu
içinde
memberın
x pro
fonksiyonunu
çağırabilir miyim
cevap
hayır
çünkü
elemanın
protected bölümü
owner'a
kapalı
diğer sınıflara
sadece türemiş
sınıflara
açık
ama bakın
aynı çağrıyı
burada
avant sınıfın
protected
fonksiyonunu
çağırabilir miyim
yani
x pro
fonksiyonunu
türemiş sınıfın
üye fonksiyonu
içinde çağırabilir miyim
cevap
evet
o zaman
üç tane tipik
containment
ile yapamadığım
ama
containment
yoluyla
kompozisyona
alternatif
olabilecek
private
kalıtımında
yapabildiğim
aslında
üç tane tipik
durum
kod
senaryo var
son kez tekrar edecek
olursak
avant sınıfın
sanal fonksiyonunu
override edebiliyorum
avant sınıfın
protected bölümüne
kendi
implementasyonumda
erişebiliyorum
ve
friend fonksiyonlarım
içinde
türemiş sınıf açısından
konuşuyorum
friend fonksiyonlarım
içinde
ya da kendi üye
fonksiyonlarım
içinde
ise
relationshipten
faydalanabiliyorum
bunun dışında
nasıl
eleman olarak
alsaydım
elemanımı
nasıl kullanacaksam
elemanı
kullanmak
yerine
taban sınıf
nesnesini
kullanabiliyorum
anlaşıldı mı
evet
bu
eğer bunlardan
birini ya da
birden fazlasını
yapacak bir tema
söz konusuysa
o zaman
ne oluyor
private kalıtı mı
containment yoluyla
kompozisyona
bir alternatif oluyor
herkes anladı mı
evet
yalnız
şimdi
tabi ki
başka farklılıklar da var
hep pozitif tarafına
bakmayalım
mesela
şu
x sınıfı yine
kalsın
n sınıfının
x sınıfında
x sınıfı türünden
birden fazla
elemanı da
olabilir
dediğimi
mesela
x sınıfı türünden
ax
bx
ama bunu doğrudan
neyle yapamam
private kalıtımıyla
yapamam
bir
taban sınıfı
kalıtımda
iki kez
kullanamam
yani böyle bir
multiple
inheritance
da yok
yani şöyle bir şey
yapabilir miyim
class match
arkadaşlar
x
takip edebiliyor muyuz
böyle bir şey
yapabilir miyim
hayır
yani bu açıdan da
bu farklılığa da
dikkat etmek gerekiyor
şimdi
private inheritance'ın
containment'a bir
alternatif oluşturduğunu
arkadaşlar
söyledik
ama bunun dışında
ilginç kullanıldığı
iki yer daha var
buraya dikkat
bir tanesi
enteresan
gerçi
c++
20 ile
biraz bu kullanım
devre dışı
kalmış olabilir
ilginç bir senaryo
için kullanılıyor
emirhan çelik
xx'den
kasıt ne
yani
taban sınıfı
iki kere kullanıyorum
multiple
inheritance'ı
daha multiple
görmediğimiz için
sentaksize tuhaf geldi
emirhan
yani şöyle
bakınız
class
a
b
multiple
inheritance bir sonraki
konumuz olduğu için
class
der
a
b
şimdi buna
multiple
inheritance deniyor
yani
a da
der sınıfının
taban sınıfı
b de taban sınıfı
burayı anladık mı
ama
aynı taban sınıf
multiple
inheritance'da
birden fazla
kullanılabiliyor mu
hayır
yani birden fazla
taban sınıfı
olabilir kalıtımda
buna multiple
inheritance deniyor
ama aynı
taban sınıf
multiple
inheritance'da
birden fazla
kez bulunamaz
şunu dedim
bunu yapamayız
ama
containment'da
örneğin
class
necin
a sınıfı
türünden
iki tane
elemanı
olabilir
bunda herhangi bir şekilde
sentax açısından
bir engel yok
hatta elemanları
a türünden olan
bir dizi olabilir
bir konteyner olabilir
bunda herhangi bir şekilde
bir problem yok
anlaşıldı mı
evet
arkadaşlar
şimdi
bir önemli özellik
daha var
dedik
gerçi
c++20'de
orada kalmıştık
buna
duyulan ihtiyaç
yok olmasa da
çok çok azalmış durumda
ama yine de
anlatayım
bakın şimdi
class
empty
bazı sınıflar
boş sınıflar
yani elemanları
yok
fakat
elemanı
olmasa da
bir sınıfın
sonuçta o sınıf
türünden
bir nesne
oluşturduğunuz zaman
bir adrese
ihtiyaç var
dolayısıyla
derleyiciler
empty
classlar için
bir byte
bir yer
ayırıyorlar
yani örneğin
empty
sınıfının
storage ihtiyacını
yazdırırsam
bir byte
olduğunu göreceksiniz
daha önce
sanırım
bundan bir kez
bahsetmiştir
class
my class
sınıfının
empty sınıfı
türünden
bir elemanı
olsun
onun
interface'ini
kullanacağım
şimdi
my class
sınıfının
size of
değerine
bakın
arkadaşlar
my class
gördüğünüz gibi
yine bir
var
ama
my class
sınıfına
bir eleman
koyalım
int
i
mta
normalde
arkadaşlar
e sınıfı
türünden
bir nesnenin
ben sadece
interface'ini
kullanıyorum
ama onu
eleman olarak
aldığımda
arkadaşlar
bakın
8'e çıktı
neden
hizanlama
nedeniyle
yani
4 byte
intten
geldi
ama normalde
bu da
1 byte
fakat
alignment
padding
yüzünden
alignment
bravo
8 byte
çıktı
fakat
şimdi
burada
containment
yoluyla
kompozisyon
yapmak yerine
private
kalıtı mı
yaptığımız zaman
derleyiciler
bu da
popüler bir
akronim
empty
base
optimization
denilen bir
optimizasyon
tekniğini
kullanıyorlar
ve tabağ sınıf
nesnesi için
türemi sınıf
de yer ayırmıyorlar
buradaki
meşhur
akronim de
EBO
empty
base
optimization
bakın şimdi
my class
sınıfını
madem
buna bir
alternatif
değil miydi
sınıf
türünden
elemana
sahip
olmak
yerine
ben
private
kalıtımını
kullanamıyor
muydum
evet
şimdi
aynı işe
private
kalıtı mı
ilerleyeyim
ve derlediğimde
arkadaşlar
my class'ın
size
of'unun
gördüğünüz gibi
4 byte
olduğunu
görüyorsunuz
yani 8 byte
olmadı
işte burada
derleyicinin
uyguladığı
arkadaşlar
optimizasyon
tekniğine
empty
base
optimization
deniyor
takip edebildik mi
evet
bir de
belki çok fazla
ihtiyaç
duyulmayabilir
ama
private
kalıtımının
kullanıldığı
ilginç bir
ideomatik
yapıya da
perp satır
restricted
polymorphism
deniyor
diyor
bu da ilginç
restricted
polymorphism
şimdi buradaki
restrict
değil
biliyorsunuz
kısıtlama
demek
arkadaşlar
dolayısıyla
restricted
polymorphism
kısıtlanmış
bu ne demek
birden fazla
fonksiyon var
fakat biz
fonksiyonlardan
seçtiğimiz
fonksiyonlara
fonksiyonlar
içinde seçtiğimiz
özel
hak vermek
istediğimiz
fonksiyonlara
polymorphismden
faydalanma
olanağı
vermek
istiyoruz
ama
tüm fonksiyonlara
değil
şöyle bir örnek
üstünde
göstermeye
çalışalım
bu da ilginç
bir tema
şimdi bakın
class
base
diyelim ki
bir sanal fonksiyon var
public
virtual
world
ve
funk
class
der
public
özellikle
kalıtı mı
yapıyorum
public
base
bu da
write
etsin
public
void
ve
punk
overwrite
şimdi burada
f1 isimli fonksiyon var
f1 fonksiyonunda
derma eder
ve
bir de
polymorphism
işlem yapan
fonksiyonumuz olsun
bu
board
base
ref
biraz kafa karıştırabilir
bu yüzden
dikkatli izleyin
evet
ve şimdi bakın
etkiler fonksiyonu içinde
foo'yu
myder nesnesiyle
çağırıyorum
tabi ki
is a relationship
olduğu için
arkadaşlar
her
der
bir
base
dir
dolayısıyla
burada
herhangi bir şekilde
bir
syntax hatası yok
yani
burada da
polymorphik işlem
yapıldığını düşünün
yani
base ref
nokta
vfunk
ve tabi
derin vfunk'ı
çağırılacak
aynı şekilde
böyle başka
fonksiyonlar olsun
void
f2
ve
void
f3
şimdi
bakınız
kalıtım
public kalıtı mı
ve bunların
hepsi
legal
eğer
kopyala
yapıştırıda
bir hata
yapmadıysak
takip edebiliyoruz
değil mi
kalıtım
private kalıtı mı
ve bunların
hepsi
syntax hatası
ama
şimdi bakın
kim
faydalansın
polymorphizmden
f1
faydalansın
print
void
f1
takip edebiliyor muyuz
bakın
f1
için
print
bildirimi
yaptığımda
kolunun başında
neden bunu
vurguladığımı
şimdi anladınız mı
f1
print
fonksiyonu
olduğu için
f1
içinde
halen
arkadaşlar
is a relationship
var mı
var
dolayısıyla
f1
içinde
full fonksiyonuna
yapılan
çağrıda
full fonksiyonunun
parametresinin
base ref
olmasına rağmen
bu çağrı
legal mi
legal
ama bakın
f2
ve f3
içinde
legalite yok
f1
içinde
tanımlanan
tüm fonksiyonlar
tüm fonksiyonlarda
erişime
sahip olacak
tam anlayamadım
fonksiyon içinde
zaten fonksiyon
tanımlayamıyoruz
ama eğer
kastınız şuysa
f1 içinde
çağrılan
bütün fonksiyonlarda
geçerli olacak
evet
özetle
private
kalıtı mı
böyle
tabi ki
private kalıtı mı
public kalıtı mı
kadar
sık kullanılmıyor
arkadaşlar
şimdi
private kalıtı mı
da
bir özelliğe
daha dikkat etmenizi
isteyeceğim
oradan
nereye varacağımı
tahmin ediyorsunuz
şimdi
base sınıfından
arkadaşlar
base sınıfının
bir public fonksiyonu
olsun
void bu
private kalıtı mı
ile
class
der
private
base
burayı biraz dikkatle
izleyelim yine
kafa karıştırabilir
evet
soru
derin üye fonksiyonu
içinde
havan sınıfının
full fonksiyonunu
çağırabilir miyim
cevap
evet
peki
derden
bir sınıf daha
elde etsem
class der
class
special der
s der
public
der
soruyu önce
anlamaya
sonra
cevap
vermeye
çalışın
void
bar
var
var fonksiyonu
içinde
sizce
full fonksiyonunu
çağırabilir miyim
legal midir
illegal midir
oğuzhan
isin
illegal
diyor
aliham
bozkır
illegal
diyor
olmaz
bütün cevaplar doğru
teşekkür ederim
olmaz
neden
çünkü artık
bu
derin
private
fonksiyonu olarak
ele alınacak
dolayısıyla
s der
arkadaşlar
derin
private
fonksiyonunu
fonksiyonuna
çağrı yapıyor
bu da
ille
zaten bakın
derleyicinin
verdiği
hata
mesajına
arkadaşlar
ne
diyor
base
for
not
accessible
because
their
uses
private
to
inherit
from
base
şimdi
kalıtını
private
yerine
protected
yaparsak
aslında
daha önce
konuştuğumuz
özellikler açısından
hiçbir fark
yok
onları uzun
uzun
söylemeyeceğim
tek fark
multi
level
inheritance
da
protected
kalıtımında
taban sınıfın
public
bölümü
türemiz
sınıfın
protected
bölümüne
ekleniyor
private
bölümüne
değil
yani
private
kalıtımında
taban sınıfın
public
bölümü
arkadaşlar
türemiz
sınıfın
private
bölümüne
eklenirken
protected
kalıtımında
taban sınıfın
public
bölümü
türemiz
sınıfın
protected
bölümüne
ekleniyor
dolayısıyla
tekrar
türetme
yaparak
üçüncü
bir sınıfı
elde ettiğimde
multi
level
inheritance
oluşturduğumda
rdk
full
fonksiyonunda
yapılan çağrı
syntax
atas
değil
çünkü
taban sınıfımın
protected
bölümüne
erişiyorum
yani
şöyle
söyleyebiliriz
değil mi
multi
level
inheritance
olmadığı
sürece
protected
kalıtımıyla
private
kalıtım
arasında
hiçbir
fark
yok
ne zaman
fark
ortaya
çıkıyor
yeni
bir sınıf
daha
multi
level
inheritance
yeni
bir sınıf
daha
oluşturduğumda
bu durumda
multi
level
inheritance
hızdaki
işte örnekteki
ester
sınıfı
kendi
taban
sınıfı
doğrudan
taban
sınıfı
olan
derin
private
bölümüne
erişemez
ama protected
bölümüne
erişebilir
base'den
dere gelen
arkadaşlar
full
fonksiyonu
da
artık
derin
protected
bölümünde
olduğu için
ester
sınıfının
implementasyonu
yani
buradaki
bar
fonksiyonu
fuya
çağrı
yapabiliyor
anladık
bunun dışında
hiçbir fark
yok
yani ancak
böyle bir
ne diyelim
motivasyonla
private
kalıtımı
yerine
protected
kalıtımını
tercih
edebilirsiniz
arkadaşlar
şimdi de
şuna
değinelim
kalıtımın
buraya kadar
geldik
private
kalıtım
ve protected
kalıtımını
da konuştuk
fakat
kalıtımda
özellikle
runtime
polimorfezimde
en çok
kullandığımız
yapılardan biri
polimorfik
listeler
yani
polimorfik
liste
olmasa
birçok
programda
kalıtıma
da ihtiyaç
duyulmayacak
runtime
polimorfezminin
en tipik
uygulama
alanı
polimorfik
listeler
liste
derken
ne kastediliyor
farklı
türden
nesneleri
onların
ortak
bir
interfeze
sahip
olduğunu
varsayarak
ya da
bilerek
onları
aynı
türdenmiş
gibi
bir kapta
bir
konteynerda
tutmak
bunu da
bir
gösterelim
arkadaşlar
mesela
bakınız
şimdi
kar sınıfı
yine
başlık
dosyamızı
ekleyelim
oyun
programında
düşünün
diyelim ki
arabalar
yarışacak
arabaların
neler
olduğu
runtime
da belli
oluyor
fakat
siz
arabaları
bir
konteynerda
örneğin
bir
vektörde
tutmak
istiyorsunuz
takip
edebiliyor
muyuz
böylece
vektörde
arabaları
tutacaksınız
ama
vektörde
tutulan
dinamik
dizide
tutulan
arabaların
her birinin
türünün
ne olduğu
programın
çalışma
zamanında
belli
oluyor
ama
siz
ister
Opel
olsun
ister
Dacia
olsun
ister
Renault
olsun
ister
Ford
olsun
bunların
araba
olma
özelliğinden
faydalanarak
bunları
konteynerda
tutabiliyorsunuz
arkadaşlar
dinamik ömürlü
nesneleri
kursun
ikinci yarısında
mercek altına
alacağız
dinamik ömürlü
nesneler
modern
C++
ile birlikte
tipik olarak
artık
aksi
yönde bir karar
almanızı
gerektirecek
bir durum
söz konusu
olmadığı
sürece
Smart
Pointer'larla
kontrol
ediliyorlar
ama ben
Smart
Pointer'lar
konusunu
henüz
anlatmadım
kursun
ikinci yarısında
çok ayrıntılı
anlatacağım
ve standart
kütüphanenin
Smart
Pointer
sınıflarında
özellikle
ayrıntılı
olarak
inceleyeceğiz
gerek
Unique
PTR
gerek
Shared
PTR
sınıflarını
şimdilik
biz eski
usul
dinamik
ömürlü
nesnelerin
adreslerini
konteynerda
tutalım
mesela
bakın şimdi
yine
konteynerler ayrıntılı
görmedikçe
enelik programlama
tarafını
yani anlamadığı
yerleri
pas geçin
önemli olan
odaklanmamız
gereken kısım
şimdilik
using
kullanıyorum
vektörün
kar yıldız
açılımı
arkadaşlar
kar vek
oyun programında
kullanılan
bizim vektörümüz
mesela
yüz kez
dönen bir
döngüyle
izleyin
arkadaşlar
kar vek
pushback
create
random car
şimdi yavaş yavaş
gidelim
create
random car
runtime'da çağrılan
bir fonksiyon
değil mi
runtime'da
oluşturulmuş
rastgele
bu
dacia'da olabilir
reno'da olabilir
falanca da olabilir
volvo'da olabilir
dinamik ömürüm
1000s'nin
adresini
tutuyor
değil mi
işte onu da
konteynere koyuyorum
şöyle
1000 de fazla
geldi
50 yapalım
şu anda
bu döngüde
yürüdükten sonra
bizim konteynırımızda
50 tane araba var
ama nedir
bu arabalar
bilmiyorum
randanda
ama bunların
araba olma
özelliğinden
faydalanarak
car interface'indeki
fonksiyonları
çağırabilirim
değil mi
mesela vektörü
dolaşayım
for
auto
chp
buradaki
döngüye ne deniyordu
range based
forlu
carvec
cout
yıldız chp
en son
böyle bir
interfez
eklemiştik
değil mi
chp
arkadaşlar
efendim
start
stop
cp
yalnız
böyle yaparsak
değerli arkadaşlar
bunları delete
etmek benim
sorumluluğumda
değil mi
void
get car
ama belki
işin
bittiği zaman
delete
cp
arada belki
başka kodlar var
alın
polimorfik listeye
bir örnek
bakın şimdi
vektörümüzde
ilk araba
adiymiş
sonraki
fiyatmış
sonra
opel
tekrar
adi
bunların
hepsi
aslında
farklı farklı
türlerden
nesneler
ben
onların
fonksiyonlarını
çağırdığımda
polimorfik işleme
yapıyorum
sanal fonksiyonlarını
çağırdığımda
function
overriding
devreye
giriyor
mercedes
de mercedes'in
start fonksiyonu
çağrılıyor
ama onların
araba olma
özelliğinden
fayda
alınarak
hepsini
ortak
bir ara
yüzde
işliyorum
işte
geçenlerde
verdiğim bir örnek
bununla
ilişkiliydi
dedim ki
bir
resim programında
resimleri
oluşturduğumuz
bir sayfa
var
fakat oradaki
şekiller
üçgen
daire
vesaire
olabiliyor
ama ben
sayfadaki
resimlerin
hepsini
adobi gibi
uygulama
düşünün
hepsini
seçim
onları
büyütebiliyorum
küçültebiliyorum
kaydırabiliyorum
onların
ortak özellikleri
shape
isimli
bir sınıfta
aslında
taban sınıftan
geliyor
ve
o
shape
nesneleri
rectangle
circle
vesaire
taban sınıfı
sanal fonksiyonlarını
override ediyorlar
evet
bugünkü dersimizde
burada sona eriyor
bir dahaki dersimizde
ilk
başlangıç
konumuz
private
özür dilerim
multiple inheritance
olacak
dan sonra
rtti
runtime type
identification
konusunu
işleyeceğiz
o da bittikten sonra
önemli yine
majör bir konumuz
exception handling
ve exception handling
ile ilgili
bütün
araçları
öğreneceğiz
derse katıldığınız için
teşekkür ediyorum
çarşamba günü
görüşmek üzere
herkese
iyi akşamlar
diliyorum
hoşçakalın
değerli arkadaşlar
abone ol